Wir blicken mal wieder auf den Investoren-Deal bei der DFL, wenn er denn überhaupt zustande kommt. Das ist schon mal die erste Frage. Inzwischen ist ja nur noch einer im Rennen und dazu will ich mal heute mit zwei besonderen Gästen sprechen. Christoph Neßhöver ist hier vom Manager-Magazin und Jannik Tillar von Kapital und die werden mir und euch heute alles erklären über Private Equity, über CVC und wie man eigentlich vielleicht auch aus einer anderen Perspektive auf diesen Deal blickt. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Ich freue mich. Und nun im Programm – der Rasenfunk.
Was müssen Sie den Private-Equity-Investoren versprechen, um das Geld zu bekommen? Was sind die Wachstum- also die Wertsteigerungsraten? Sind die berühmten Verdopplungen alle zwei Jahre, Vervierfachungen in vier Jahren? Ist das das, was Sie sagen müssen?
Jetzt kaufe ich Unternehmen, also zum Beispiel Douglas, das kennen Sie Tipico, Messer-Industriegase, Breitling. Deswegen muss ich eine Breitling-Uhr auch tragen. Kaufen wir, behalten wir dann vier bis fünf Jahre, versuchen, von good to great, also ein gutes Unternehmen noch besseres zu machen und dann mehr Geld zu verkaufen.
Wir haben gehört im Intro Christoph Käse, Host mit Host des Podcasts Hi im Gespräch mit Tina Müller. Die hören wir vielleicht später in dieser Sendung noch. Und dann haben wir gehört, den Deutschlandchef von CVC, dem einzig verbliebenen möglichen Partner für die DFL, Alexander Dibelius. Und jetzt werden wir hören, unter anderem Christoph Neßhöver vom Manager-Magazin. Hi Christoph, schön, dass du da bist. Ja, ich freue mich total, dass diese Sendung geklappt hat und dass wir auch Jannik Tillar hier haben, von Kapital. Hallo Jannik. So, erste Frage an euch beide. Christoph, du darfst beginnen. Hat es dich denn überrascht? Wir haben ja schon vor ein paar Wochen gesprochen über diese Sendung, dass in dem Zeitraum dazwischen die Fanproteste, die wir ja auch gehört haben im Intro, schon dazu geführt haben, dass sich Blackstone, der zweite Mitbieter, schon aus dem Rennen gezogen hat und jetzt die DFL nur noch mit CVC verhandelt.
Also überrascht hat es mich schon ein bisschen, weil diese Unternehmen, über die wir heute reden wollen, eigentlich nicht dafür bekannt sind, dass sie, wenn sie sich mal was vorgenommen haben, das so leicht wieder einfach hinschmeißen, weil die stecken ja enorm viel Geld und Arbeit da rein, um so einen Pitch zu gewinnen. Also so ein Pitch heißt eben Bieterverfahren, wie das die DFL da angestoßen hat. Ich würde aber eine Sache direkt ein bisschen anders formulieren. Du hast gesagt, wegen der Proteste. Ich glaube, die Proteste selber waren eigentlich nicht der Grund. Das haben die schon einkalkuliert, dass denen klar war, in was für ein Umfeld die sich begeben, wenn sie sich um so einen Einstieg bemühen. Ich glaube, was die mehr frustriert hat, war die Reaktion der Fußballbosse, weil die eigentlich erwartet haben, dass die DFL hat sich mehrheitlich – kommen wir vielleicht noch zu – entschieden, wir gehen das an, wir machen das, wir geben der DFL ein Verhandlungsmandat. Dann kommt der erwartbare Protest der Fans. Man kann jetzt sagen, vielleicht hat man es so energisch, konsequent, flächendeckend nicht erwartet. Wäre vielleicht ein bisschen naiv, wenn sie das nicht gemacht hätten. Und dann hatten die das Gefühl, dass es eigentlich zu lang gedauert hat, bis sich die DFL und die wichtigsten Leute da klar positioniert haben und gesagt haben, ja, das sind die Fans, die haben da ihre Sorgen. Wir wiederholen nochmal, macht euch keine Sorgen, wie immer gesagt wurde bisher, wir stehen dazu. Und ich glaube, da hat sich dann Blackstone gefragt, können die sich gefragt haben, ist das der richtige Partner für uns? Ich glaube eher, dass das, also es war sozusagen eine indirekte Ableitung jetzt, aber ich glaube, das war wichtiger als die Proteste an sich, weil diese Typen sind ja nicht naiv, denen war ja klar, in was für ein Umfeld die sich begeben, oder ist klar, und dass die Fans Gegenwind entfachen würden, war denen auch klar. Also ich glaube, das Problem war eher die Reaktion des Fußballs.
Also ich will mich da eigentlich nur anschließen letztlich und ich glaube auch, ein Grund, der dazu geführt hat, dass Black Sun sich zurückgezogen hat, scheint ja auch, das zeigt ja auch die Aussage der DFL, die ja ein Statement nachher veröffentlicht hat, dass man sich schon sehr klar im Vorfeld so Richtung CVC positioniert hat und dass Black Sun einfach auch gesehen hat, dass die Chancen sehr gering sind und das, wie Christoph ja auch gesagt hat, dass die Mittel, die dort investiert werden, Personal, dass sich mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzen muss, gebunden wird. Und ja, da hatte man wahrscheinlich einfach auch keine Lust mehr, dieses Personal dafür zu binden. Und wenn man ständig nur hört, man ist die zweite Geige, dann ja, ich glaube, das frustriert und das hat auch letztlich einen Grund dafür, warum sich Black Sun zurückgezogen hat.
Jetzt seid ihr ja beide in dem Thema tief drin, vor allem von Kapitalseite logischerweise. Das ist ja euer Blick auf den ganzen Prozess. Hattet ihr auch den Eindruck – wir können da jetzt nur im Subjektiven bleiben – dass CVC von Anfang an aus all den anderen möglichen Private-Equity-Geldgebern hervorgeragt ist? Ich habe von einem Partner, bei dem ich mich unterhalten habe, das Wort des Scheinbieterverfahrens gehört. Das ist jetzt natürlich dann eine Unterstellung, aber ich glaube, ihr wisst, in welche Richtung es da geht. Christoph, ist dir sowas auch untergekommen?
Ja, das ist mir auch untergekommen. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich meine, das wisst ihr beide auch. Wenn man mit den Fußballmanagern redet, dann wird unglaublich viel kolportiert. Wer hat wann mit dem für Mittag gesessen, welcher Sponsor wiederum hat, mal CVC für irgendwas beauftragt, also Sponsor von einem Club. Da gibt es, wie soll ich sagen, hunderte Geschichten, aber viele. Und klar ist, dass es in diesem Prozess sehr schwierig ist für die DFL – guck mal vielleicht auch noch mal drauf – eine klare Mehrheit oder klare Richtung zu verfolgen und dass da ständig irgendwie kolportiert wird, der und der ist da. Also in meinen Einungen war das nicht. Ich habe das zwar auch gehört, der eine sagt, CVC liegt vorne, der andere sagt, Blackstone liegt vorne. Da gibt es ja diese Geschichten mit irgendwelchen ehemaligen DFL-Mitarbeiter, die mittlerweile für Blackstone oder Fernblitzer arbeiten. Da gibt es ganz, ganz viel und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, wenn man diesen Prozess jetzt mal ganz nüchtern betrachtet, dann geht es am Ende darum, dass die DFL möglichst viel Geld bekommt. Und ich glaube nicht, dass am Ende CVC den Zutrag bekommen hätte, wenn es noch mehrere Bieter gäbe, wenn die merklich weniger geboten hätten. Das heißt, es kommt darauf an, dass genug Geld zusammenkommt zunächst mal. Das ist ja auch wichtig für die Argumentation, dann in die Liga rein. Das heißt, wenn es das Rennen noch gäbe, dann wäre es auf den Preis angekommen. Und ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass das schon so vornherein entschieden war. Aber vielleicht sieht Janu das anders.
Mir ist das Wort auch untergekommen in den Vorgesprächen. Es ist zumindest so, dass CVC ja die Einschläge bekannt ist dafür, dass sie viele Sportinvestitionen getätigt haben und dass man dort gewisse Vorkenntnisse mitbringt. Aus der Perspektive war CVC glaube ich immer vorne. Also, dass man sagt, das war der Investor, der uns strategisch nach vorne bringen kann, wenn man von diesem Wort strategischer Partner spricht. Dann lag CVC glaube ich immer vorne. Aber wie Christoph auch sagt, das Geld ist natürlich nicht unwichtig. Und wenn dort ein anderer, ob es Blackstone war, ob es EQT war, das waren also die drei letzten, die dort noch im Rennen waren. Wenn da einer mehr geboten hätte, ich glaube, das wäre auf jeden Fall zu einem sehr wichtigen Argument in letzter Instanz herangewachsen.
Ich glaube, man darf auch noch eins nicht vergessen, es gibt auch viele in der Bundesliga, die CVC nicht trauen. Gerade deswegen, weil sie so viel Erfahrung haben. Es ist ein bisschen irr, aber gerade wegen der Investments von CVC in Frankreich, in die Liga und in Spanien. Weil dann nämlich einige sagen, naja, wenn ich mir das jetzt angucke, dann jonglieren die mit drei rechten Paketen, die mit Konkurrenten von uns, weil die Bundesliga sieht schon, gerade Spanien als Konkurrent natürlich, um da hinter der Premier League Platz zwei global in der Aufmerksamkeit zu belegen, was nicht so einfach ist. Und da hatte man dann auch, das gab eine ganze Menge Leute, die das Gefühl hatten, dass das dann oder haben, dass das nicht so optimal ist, wenn CVC dann da so eine Art von Paket hat und die einige an den anderen ausspielen kann. Weil das war die Sorge. Jetzt sagen natürlich CVC, ja, das sind alles getrennte Teams und da gibt es dann Chinese Word, der eine darf dem anderen nichts wissen, obwohl die in der selben Firma arbeiten, ist natürlich ein bisschen naiv. Oder naiv, wenn man das glaubt, ist es naiv. Das sehe ich auch kritisch, dass das so durchhaltbar ist. Auch, dass in Gesprächen dann die Private Equity Leute gesagt haben, wenn man dann zusammenkommt, in Australien ein Paket anbieten auf dem Medienmarkt mit drei Ligen. Das ist doch viel besser. Dann kriegen wir doch viel bessere Preise. Was dadurch dagegen spricht, dass es Chinese Word gibt. Das ist ein bisschen irre oder nicht ganz überzeugend, sage ich mal. Aber das ist schon ein wichtiger Punkt, dass man da Angst hat, dass da Wissen abfließt in die Richtung der anderen Ligen und dass am Ende dann der Partner sagt, naja, vielleicht ist jetzt gerade Spanien attraktiver da und dort und dann pushe ich das mehr, als die Bundesliga dann vielleicht ins Spiel bringe und dass du dann eigentlich als Bundesliga eher noch verlierst. Den Verlass gibt es natürlich auch.
Klar, also jetzt könnte man natürlich die ketzerische Gegenfrage bringen und fragen, was bringt das CVC, wenn man die Bundesliga schlechter verkauft als die anderen Ligen. Das wäre so die logische Frage, die man anschließen könnte. Es bringt ja wirklich gar nichts. Sie wollen ja jede einzelne Investition möglichst groß machen und von daher ist das halt das Gegenargument, was angeführt wird. Da kann man von halten, was man will. Ich glaube schon, dass es wirklich ein großes Interesse darin gibt, dass man alle möglichst groß machen möchte. Aber an Chinese Walls muss ich deshalb trotzdem nicht glauben.
Ja, vor allem also wer sich historisch mit der chinesischen Mauer mal befasst, der wird merken, die hatte ja nicht nur eine Wirkung nach außen, dass keiner reinkommt, sondern auch von innen, dass keiner rauskommt. Also vielleicht kann man es dann so rum sehen. Und CVC setzt halt dann einfach auf Fußball als Thema und als Markt und verspricht sich da Wachstumsschancen. Und dann ist es ja aus CVC-Sicht gar nicht so schlecht, quasi drei Eier im Korb zu haben und das vierte Serie A Ei, wer weiß, ob man da vielleicht dann doch noch irgendwie dran kommt. Dann kann eigentlich nichts passieren. Aber glaubt ihr denn Christoph, dass mal beginnen, dass sich die Verhandlungsposition der DFL jetzt wirklich merklich verschlechtert hat, dadurch, dass man eben nur noch mit einem Bieter spricht?
Also das ist ja der Sinn des Bieterverfahrens, dass ich zumindest zwei habe, die ich stückweit hochschaukeln kann. Wobei man natürlich auch sagen muss, die ursprünglichen Gebote lagen ja nicht weit auseinander. Also das war ja nicht so, dass der eine jetzt viel, viel mehr geboten hätte, nach allem, was man weiß. Lagen die fast gleich auf. Das heißt, da verliere ich jetzt nicht so viel. Aber es geht da jetzt darum, das Angebot zu konkretisieren. Jetzt haben die sich die Daten angeguckt, die haben alle Zahlen intern, die die DFL hat, liefern kann über ihre Geschäfte praktisch dem möglichen Partner geöffnet. Das hatte Blackstone auch schon angefangen. Da verrätst du schon ein bisschen deine Geschäftsgeheimnisse. Aber das musst du eben machen. Und jetzt geht CVC halt hin und macht nochmal, ich glaube bis nächste Woche oder so, das finale Angebot. Wenn die jetzt da irgendwas finden, wo die sagen, das sieht aber nicht so gut aus, dann kann es natürlich sein, dass die jetzt sagen, wir hatten jetzt da etwas über eine Milliarde geboten, der hat nur noch 900 Millionen oder so. Das ist nicht ausgeschlossen. Die Jungs sind harte Verhandler. Also die Belios über den Tisch zu ziehen, ist glaube ich nicht ganz so einfach. Das ist eher umgekehrt, das Risiko. Das ist natürlich ein Risiko. Andererseits wissen die natürlich auch als möglicher Partner, dass der Preis zentral ist. Und dass das auch für die DFL natürlich, wenn die das durchkriegen wollen, extrem wichtig ist, dass die da ungefähr auf ihrer Zielmarke landen. Weil wenn Herr Watzke dann hingeht in der Liga, als er erklären muss, das kriegen wir doch leider nur noch 800 Millionen oder 900 Millionen oder so, dann wird es natürlich fast unmöglich, das zu rechtfertigen.
So mal es ja auch nächste Woche dann diese Abstimmung geben soll noch über diesen finalen Deal.
Ja klar, das spitzt sich jetzt ja alles zu in den nächsten zwei Wochen. Das weiß natürlich CVC auch, dass die da schwer jetzt richtig auf den Preis nochmal prügeln können mit irgendwelchen Argumenten. Deswegen denke ich an sich, der Nachteil, den die DFL jetzt hat, der größere Nachteil ist die Tatsache, dass der Partner ausgestiegen ist. Also, dass die DFL als Partner offensichtlich nicht mehr so attraktiv für jemanden wie Blackstone ist. Das ist glaube ich für die Landwirtlich oder für die Mittelfundlich schädlicher, als dass sie jetzt nur noch einen Verhandlungspartner haben, wo die Gefahr, dass sich das Ergebnis jetzt so arg groß von dem ersten Angriff unterscheidet, meiner Meinung nach überschaubar ist.
Es gab ja auch kurzfristig mal Überlegungen, dass man wieder EQT ins Boot holt und quasi so künstlich noch einen zweiten Bieter hinzufügt. Aber das scheint ja dadurch, dass es jetzt in der kommenden Woche schon diese Abstimmung geben soll, auch mittlerweile ausgeschossen. Es wird ja dann zwangsläufig auf einen Bieter hinauslaufen, also auf CVC und das kann nie im Leben zu einer Steigerung des Erlöses für die DFL führen. Das kann mir keiner erzählen.
Das sicher nicht. Das glaube ich auch nicht. Aber ich glaube halt auch nicht, dass die Gefahr so unheimlich groß ist, dass die jetzt noch einen riesen Discount da rausverhandeln, also Bibelius und Co.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob die sich so eine Rücktrittsversicherung in den Vertrag geben lassen bei den Medienverträgen, die jetzt ja anstehen. Das ist halt wirklich der entscheidende Punkt für die Medienverträge, die jetzt dann im zweiten oder dritten Quartal ungefähr verhandelt und abgeschlossen werden sollen. Da muss man mal die Rechnung aufmachen. Da kommen wir vielleicht noch drauf.
Also das heißt, du meinst mit Rücktrittsversicherung oder ihr beide, weil Christoph nickt sehr heftig, jetzt dann wahrscheinlich im Mai wird die neue TV-Rechtevergabe für die nächsten Saisons dann eben vergeben und sollte da ein Rückgang zum Beispiel in den Einnahmen sein, dass dann CVC nochmal rauskäme aus dem Deal?
Ganz genau. Also nicht zurückgehen, aber ich würde sagen, das ist jetzt Angebot erstmal verringern. Wir gehen jetzt mal einfach halber von einer Milliarde aus, dass man dann nicht mehr eine Milliarde zahlt, sondern 900, 800 Millionen, wie auch immer. Das haben die sich ja angeblich reinverhandeln lassen, dass man dort nochmal nachverbessern kann aus Sicht des Investors oder ja, das ist natürlich auch noch abstimmungsbedürftig dann bei der DFL, aber das wird auf jeden Fall noch spannend. Also es ist nicht nur, weil jetzt in der kommenden Woche eventuell der Deal durchgewunken wird, dann auch wirklich alles abgeschlossen.
Das ist ja im Prinzip, so erklärt sich ja auch das Timing. Also es war ja von vornherein klar, dass man diese strategische Partnerschaft abgeschlossen haben möchte, bevor man in den Bieterprozess für die nächsten vier Jahre geht und zwar zum einen aus zwei Gründen. Zum einen, weil man natürlich hofft, dass man dadurch den Gesamtwert etwas nach oben regen kann, weil man dann den Medienpartnern sagen kann, wir haben ja jetzt auch einen Partner und das wird alles noch viel besser werden und das heißt die Wertehaltigkeit steigt. Und zum zweiten, weil man natürlich gefusst hat oder das Risiko hat, wenn die Medienauktion nicht so toll läuft, wie es ja in allen Ländern auch jetzt war in letzter Zeit, also dass die Preise nicht mehr ständig steigen, so wie das jetzt 15, 20 Jahre lang der Fall war, dann hast du natürlich auch löchterere Brandesbrötchen mit deinem strategischen Partner. Und das heißt, die haben schon auch ein bisschen den Private-Equities jetzt gesagt, wir wollen, dass ihr jetzt faktisch Fakten schafft, bevor wir eigentlich die aktuelle Wertehaltigkeit des Medienpakets richtig kennen, weil die bindet sich also am Markt mit der Ausschreibung. Und zum Beispiel Iguoté hat das sehr früh gesagt, dass die auf jeden Fall nachverhandeln wollen und das ist dann zumindest in der ersten Runde. Daran sind die eigentlich auch mit gescheitert, weil man das eigentlich nicht wollte. Und soweit ich weiß, hat das die DFL das Präsidium auch ziemlich deutlich abgelehnt, dass man das nicht machen möchte. Ob jetzt natürlich trotzdem so eine Klausel da reinkommt in den Vertrag, dass man eben – ich glaube nicht, dass es um Ausstieg geht, ehrlich gesagt. Es geht darum, wenn die jetzt mit CVC vereinbaren, die machen das und das geht überall durch. Und dann kommt im Juni, Juli, August, kommt dann die Einigung mit den Medienrechnungen, die liegt halt 20 Prozent unter dem, was man bisher hatte, dass dann eben CVC eine Klausel ziehen kann und sagen kann, so, jetzt wissen wir aber, die Wertehaltigkeit ist ja dessen, wo wir eingestiegen sind, ist gesunken am Markt, zumindest für die nächsten vier Jahre. Deswegen möchten wir jetzt, haben wir auch das Recht nochmal zu verhandeln und zahlen angeblich entsprechend weniger. Also konkret, wenn wir jetzt mal an die Landen bei 800 Millionen im Jahr im Schnitt für die nächsten vier Jahre, jetzt haben wir gerade so 1, 1, glaube ich, gerade ohne Ausland, 1, 1 Milliarden, dann würde CVC halt von 1 Milliarden auf 800 Millionen runtergehen. Die Gefahr ist da und ist schon möglich, dass jetzt, wo die richtig Not haben, dass sie unbedingt den Deal wollen, dass sie dann sagen, wir räumen euch das ein, obwohl das vor ein paar Monaten noch, oder ein paar Wochen noch, eigentlich undenkbar war, dass man dem Partner das einräumen, dass er noch nachverhandeln darf, weil das wollte man ja gerade vermeiden.
Das war ja genau eins der Argumente dafür, dass ein möglicher Partner auch so einen Rückgang mittragen würde, also er trägt dann auch das Risiko mit, was ja immer noch so ist, aber dann ein bisschen abgeschwächt.
Das mag sein, aber nie im Leben würde CVC einen Deal machen auf Basis von 800 Millionen. Also das kann man relativ leicht runterrechnen. Also wenn man sagt, man hat 800 Millionen im Vergleich zu 1, 1 Medieneinnahmen, also es ist ein Rückgang von 300 Millionen, dann ja, also für Investoren ist halt diese IAA sehr wichtig, dass die sowas wie der interne Zinsfuß und wenn man jetzt gesagt, man hat 8 Prozent von 800 Millionen, das sind 64 Millionen pro Jahr und wenn man das über 20 Jahre hochrechnet, dann sind das ja 1, 28 Milliarden, glaube ich, im Jahr über die 20 Jahre, die ja dieser Vertrag laufen soll, als wäre dann irgendwie, man könnte jetzt zwar sagen, 280 Millionen gewonnen, cool, Brotorenite von 28 Prozent, aber das ist natürlich nicht ganz so leicht, wenn man, ja, das muss man natürlich über die Zeit auch abdiskontieren, das machen die mit dieser IAA, das ist jetzt, ich will jetzt gar nicht zu tief da ins Detail gehen, aber wenn man das macht, dann kommt man dabei bei einer IAA von 2, 5 Prozent raus, das heißt, die interne, also diese Diskontierungssatz von 2, 5 Prozent bedeutet, Das bedeutet, dass man Investitionen nur tätigen sollte, wenn man die Kapitalkosten unterhalb dieser 2, 5 Prozent hat und weil das aktuelle Zinseniveau von 3, 75 Prozent CVC kann sich mit Sicherheit sehr günstig verschulden oder kann auf jeden Fall sehr günstig an Geld kommen, ist das jedenfalls kein lukrativer Deal mit 800 Millionen Euro. Und ich habe mir das auch mal durchgerechnet, wie man das steigern müsste, dass man auf die Medianrendite von 16 Prozent kommt, die ja Private Equity in den vergangenen Jahren eigentlich immer gemacht hat. Und da müsste man mal, jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus, dass sie wie auch immer oder warum auch immer das aktuelle Niveau von 1, 1 Milliarden halten können, dann würde das aber bedeuten, dass der V-Vertrag in der letzten Periode, die werden ja immer für vier Jahre verhandelt, diese TV-Verträge und das heißt im letzten, im fünften TV-Vertrag, müsste man neun Milliarden Euro einnehmen pro Saison und das halte ich für sehr ambitioniert, sagen wir mal so.
Also mehr als die Premier League jetzt bekommt. Richtig. Und zwar recht vierfache von dem, was die Premier League jetzt bekommt.
Ganz genau, ja. Also so wie ich es gehört habe, soll es jetzt nicht ganz so schlimm sein, es soll ja so bei 30 bis 50 Prozent pro rechte Periode erhöht werden, das hat man schon ein, zwei Mal geschafft. Das ist aber immer noch sehr ambitioniert, gemessen an dem, wie die Entwicklung aktuell einfach ist. Und deswegen glaube ich, mit den Zahlen, die aktuell im Raum sind, 800 Millionen, wird es auf jeden Fall nicht zu diesem Deal für eine Milliarde kommen.
Ja gut, und die Frage ist auch, wie hat man diese Steigerung in der Vergangenheit geschafft? Durch Zerstückelung des Spieltags, immer mehr Einzelspiele und so weiter und so fort. Und dieses Rad wirst du nicht ewig weiter drehen können. Da dreht man zwar immer noch jetzt auch zur nächsten Rechtevergabe dran, mehr Sonntagsspiele. Natürlich nur, weil die armen Europapokal-Teilnehmer so müde sind. Aber das ist es ja eben. Also es wird sich nicht mehr endlos weiter drehen lassen. Vor allem, wenn es angeblich wirklich diese roten Linien gibt, von denen so viel gesprochen wird. Aber das bringt ja eigentlich uns direkt zu der Frage, Jannik, warum macht denn das CVC dann überhaupt? Also weil es ist ja nicht davon auszugehen, dass man diese Renditen, die man sonst so hat, da wirklich bekommen wird und gleichzeitig Private Equity – wir werden gleich, glaube ich, noch drüber sprechen müssen, was das eigentlich genau ist. Aber es zeichnet sich eben unter anderem dadurch aus, dass du eben 16 Prozent, 20 Prozent Rendite – wir haben es ja auch im Intro, deswegen habe ich diesen Schnipsel mit reingenommen – das ist das Normale. Also normalerweise, wenn ein Private Equity Fund irgendwo einsteigt, dann geht da mit der Rendite-Erwartung ran. Wir haben es im Intro gehört, Verdopplung innerhalb von zwei Jahren, Vervierfachung innerhalb von vier Jahren. Ist das auch wirklich das, was CVC erhofft sich von der Zusammenarbeit mit der DFL?
Also ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt, es wird eher von 30 bis 50 Prozent innerhalb der Rechteperioden gerechnet. Das ist ein bisschen was anderes. Und man müsste es auch missunterscheiden von klassischen Private Equity Deals. Also klassische Private Equity Deals sind ja Buyouts von Unternehmen. Also es gibt die Firma Renk, das ist ein ganz gutes Beispiel aktuell. Das ist ein Marineschifffahrtshersteller, ein Getriebehersteller letztlich aus Augsburg. Das Private Equity Triton hat letztens vor vier, fünf Jahren von der Börse genommen, hat es jetzt quasi komplett saniert und hat es dann jetzt – ich weiß gar nicht – zum Dreifachen des Preises wieder an die Börse gebracht. Das ist so ein klassischer Deal, man kauft ein Unternehmen von der Börse, restrukturiert es, macht es effizienter und verkauft es gewinnbringend an der Börse wieder. Dieser Deal ist ja ganz anders, also man ist ja letztlich nur an den Einkommensströmen, an den Cashflows auf Englisch beteiligt und es macht diese ganze Rechnung ja anders. Man kann letztlich nur alle vier Jahre, grob gesagt alle vier Jahre, mit der neuen Ausschreibung der TV-Rechte – klar, man kann jetzt noch Lizenzrechte und so dazunehmen, aber dieser ganz große Topf sind einfach die TV-Töpfe – kann man alle vier Jahre versuchen, mehr Geld rauszuhandeln und da muss CVC irgendwas sehen, was ich nicht sehe oder die zahlen einfach auch viel weniger als das, was aktuell im Raum steht. Man weiß es nicht, also ja, sie würden es nicht machen, wenn sie nicht da einen ziemlich sicheren Case sehen würden, also ein Szenario, wo sie dann diese 30 bis 50 Prozent zwischen jeder rechten Periode steigern könnten. Also ein Punkt ist sicher dann dieses Plattformmodell, wo sie sich ganz große Einnahmen im Ausland erhoffen. Da können wir vielleicht auch später nochmal dazukommen, wie dieser einzelne Topf aussieht, was man da machen will und ob es dann zu diesen 30 bis 50 Prozent kommt, muss man schauen.
Also ich glaube, dass diese Prozentzahlen, die man da den Private-Equities als Zielmarken immer zurechnet, dass die ein bisschen verwirrend sind. Also man muss das ein bisschen differenzierter betrachten, finde ich. Das sind natürlich erst mal immer Mittelwerte. Und ich meine, so eine CVC, so eine Private-Equity-Firma wie CVC, die sind so groß, also die legen Fonds auf. So einen zweistelligen Milliardenbetrag in Dollar, wo die dann eben aus denen heraus investieren. Natürlich, wie jeder andere Investor auch, jeder Größere, streuen die das. Die sind schon in der Lage zu entscheiden, welche Deals mache ich, die vielleicht so wie Renk ein enormes Steigungsprinzell haben, weil ich eben nur Sachen machen kann, wie ich nehme die von der Börse, punkte die auf und verkaufe die wieder. Und welche Deals ich mache, wo ich sage, die brauche ich vielleicht für die Mischung, weil die sehr stetige Einnahmen garantieren, so wie du das gesagt hast. Da geht es um den Cashflow. Die wissen, dass sie ja keine, streng genommen – das sagt ja auch die DFL immer, das stimmt ja auch – streng genommen nicht eine Beteiligung am deutschen Fußball erwerben, die sie immer wieder verkaufen können, sondern eine Beteiligung an den Rechten, an den Medienrechten, an einem Teil der Verwertung. Und das bekommen die. Und natürlich ist es so, oder es ist so, Fußball ist halt seit 20 Jahren ein Wachstumsmarkt, völlig unabhängig von Konjunktur und irgendwas. Also es gibt mittlerweile ja eine eigene Assetklasse Fußball. Und zwar deswegen, weil die Investoren, nicht nur CVC, auch andere sagen, das ist total stabil. Das geht immer weiter hoch, egal ob, ich sag mal, Putin die Ukraine überfällt oder ob wir eine Finanzkrise kriegen. Selbst in der Corona-Zeit hat das ja noch so eine kleine Delle gegeben und es läuft einfach gut weiter. Und das ist was, was für Investoren auch attraktiv ist. Die stecken da Geld rein und kriegen halt jedes Jahr stabil eine Aufsicht. Und selbst wenn man 20 Jahre betrachtet, ist die Gefahr, dass das irgendwie ausfällt, diese Einnahmen, ist sehr, sehr gering aus deren Sicht. Und deswegen machen die das. Also aus meiner Sicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass die dieselben Gewinnerwartungen haben wie bei solchen Inside- also Einstiegs-Ausstiegs-Deals. Kannste auch gar nicht haben. Und die Fantasie, die dann da drin steckt, für einen wirklich großen Reibach, den die natürlich gerne machen würden, weil das eben so ein bisschen die Natur der Private Equity ist, dass sie besonders große Renditen anstreben und entsprechende Risiken eingehen, ist halt, wie schon gesagt, diese Streaming-Plattform, in der man hofft, dass man da was aufstellt mit dem investierten Geld. Das will ja die DFL auch, was viel moderner, weitgehenderes, was man bisher anbietet und vor allem, was ein eigenes DFL-CVC in dem Fall Produkt wäre. Und das, was sich dann bei der übernächsten rechte Ausschreibung, also ab 2028, dann soll es ja stehen, vermarkten kann als ein ganz anderes Produkt, als was ich jetzt habe. Also diese relativ langweiligen Bilder auch bestanden, die immer gleich sind. Dann kommen diese Themen mit Mannschaftsbus und bei Bill Bauer beten sie vorher in der Kabine, das liest man jetzt in Spanien schon und so weiter. Das heißt, das ist das, was die eigentlich hoffen. Dann hoffen die das, das ist glaube ich das, die Fantasie, die die Leute von CVC da haben, dann sie sagen und dann, das ist auch das, was die Bayern schon lange hoffen, ja und auch Herr Watzke, dass dann plötzlich Amazon kommt oder Apple TV und sagt, pass mal auf, Leute, das ist so cool, wir kaufen das sozusagen für die ganze Welt und dann rollen wir das aus. Und dann kannst du natürlich ganz andere Preise aufrufen und du hast ein eigenes Produkt hingestellt. Also ob das funktioniert, weiß natürlich kein Mensch. Und das ist das Risiko, was die Private Acquities dann gemeinsam mit der DFL da eingehen oder wozu das Kapital von CVC dann eingesetzt werden kann. Das kann aber auch furchtbar in die Hose gehen und nicht funktionieren und dann krautest du auf CVC-Sicht relativ bescheidenen Niveau weiter. Aber die haben immer eine Sicherheit, die Einnahmen, die werden die kriegen und dann haben sie immer noch einen positiven, also sie gewinnen immer noch Geld, klar, wenn sie es kein Geld verdienen, würden sie es nicht machen. Aber ich habe jetzt viel gesagt, aber ich wollte sagen, diese Renditeerwartungen sind eben schon sehr unterschiedlich, was das jeweilige Investment angeht. Also ich befreite mal ein Beispiel, Max, wenn ich das noch darf, wo wir auch investiert haben. Die Firma, die ich ein bisschen kenne. CVC ist Minderheitsinvestor bei DKV Mobility, kennt wahrscheinlich fast niemand. Wer öfter an Autobahnradstätten ist, der kennt diese grünen Aufkleber, DKV. Das ist keine Krankenkasse, sondern das ist ein Familienunternehmen, ich glaube, die kommen aus Münsterland irgendwoher, Familie Fischer heißen die, glaube ich, die das hochgezogen haben. Das ist ein Prinzip, ein Abrechnungssystem, also das heißt, die ganzen Speditionen zum Beispiel, die Fahrer, die kriegen so eine DKV-Karte, das setzt DKV alles auf. Wenn die dann ihren Sprit bezahlen müssen für den Laster, dann müssen sie nichts zahlen, legen die Karte hin und Ende, wie so eine Kreditkarte eigentlich. Und das ist ein riesen B2B-Geschäft, das ist riesig, die machen, ich glaube, 12, 13 Milliarden Umsatz. Familienunternehmen, die haben sich vor einigen Jahren überlegt, um zu wachsen, um Kapital zu bekommen, um weiteres Wachstum zu machen. Die haben so ein E-Ladesäulen-Netz, ziehen die hoch und so. Also die müssen ja mit der Zeit gehen und das ist unheimlich teuer. Haben die gesagt, wir holen uns CVC rein oder wir suchen uns einen Partner. Und das CVC hat den Zutrag gekriegt. Das heißt seit einigen Jahren ist CVC, ich glaube, mit ein Drittel oder so beteiligt, an einem stockkonservativen, relativ langweiligen deutschen Serviceunternehmen für den Logistikbereich, was Riesenumsätze hat, aber relativ geringe Gewinne. Weil das natürlich, das ist so ein System, du musst ganz froh sein, um da genug rauszuziehen und eigentlich stinkt langweilig. So und dann geht CVC rein, sagt, wir geben, wir kaufen euch ein Stück ab und wir helfen euch dabei. Warum machen die das? Ich kann nur sagen, ich verstehe es so, das ist auch so ein Beispiel. Die wissen, das ist ein Geschäft, was über Jahre stabile Cashflows produziert. Das kann man schon ein bisschen vergleichen mit den Steigerungsraten. Kann man vielleicht ein bisschen was machen, aber riesig wachsen werden, die wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht. Aber das garantiert mir eine sehr stabile Rendite, die wird auch nicht astronomisch dann auf mein eingesetztes Kapital. Und auch solche Deals machen die, und das machen die auch deswegen, weil die eben auch das im Portfolio brauchen. Und die werden dann gleichzeitig in der nächsten Runde vielleicht irgendeinen Unternehmen wieder von der Börse nehmen und hoffen, dass sie das in zwei Jahren für das Fünf-Fache zurückbringen werden, verkaufen können. Das ist ja alles in deren Geschäftsstrategie mit drin.
Ja, wobei das finde ich jetzt interessant, weil gerade bei DKV Mobility, die wollten sie ja jetzt eigentlich an die Börse bringen und machen es nicht, weil gerade das Zinsumfeld nicht attraktiv genug ist. Also sprich, und das ist nämlich eine der Fragen, die ich mir stelle.
Bei ihrem eigenen Börsengang auch.
Ja genau, ihren eigenen Börsengang haben sie deswegen auch verschoben. Und das ist eigentlich schon mal gleich eine Kernfrage, auch wenn wir jetzt quasi ein bisschen vorgreifen. Aber ich habe hier, um eben quasi zu verdeutlichen, wie CVC funktioniert, wir haben einmal Alexander Dibellius gehört und wir hören mal kurz, das ist der kürzere O-Ton, Dibellius spiele ich dann später noch mal vor, Stefan Smaller, der war im Online-Marketing Rockstars Podcast, ist bei der Quality Group mit drin, die machen Mourn Nutrition und ISN, riesig tolle Geschichte, aber auch, na, googelt es, gibt viele, viele Artikel zu und der erzählt aber mal kurz, weil der hat nämlich einen Private Equity Hintergrund, wie das eigentlich funktioniert und bringt das sehr gut auf den Punkt. Und dann wäre die Frage an euch, ist das vielleicht auch eine Strategie von CVC gegenüber der DFL, selbst wenn wir jetzt, wir gehen mit der These rein, sie wollen die ständige Rendite und es ist quasi ein Mix in ihrem Gesamtportfolio oder wollen sie vielleicht doch sowas wie hier?
Bewertungen sind einfach volatil, darauf fokussieren wir uns nicht und wirklich nicht. Also am Ende muss natürlich ein Private Equity Investor, der investiert hat, wir müssen irgendwann die Firma zu einem Exit bringen, also da wird es entweder einen Börsengang geben oder einen Verkauf oder eine Partnerschaft mit jemandem, das muss man alles schauen.
Also die Frage, Jannik, nach dem Exit, weil DKV auch der Exit eigentlich schon geplant war, jetzt verschoben und ich gehe davon aus, die haben vom ADAC ja irgendwie diese 1, 3 Millionen Karten, die sie jetzt mit verwalten, also haben quasi neuen Teil ins Geschäft reingehört, jetzt sind sie börsengangfähig, nur das Marktumfeld passt gerade nicht. Könnte das nicht mit der DFL auch passieren, dass man zum Beispiel sagt, okay, erste rechte Vergabe, da wird es noch nicht so viel, da haben wir noch nicht so viel machen können, dann bauen wir aber die OTT-Plattform und vielleicht vor der zweiten Rechtevergabe, wenn man dann schon sagen kann, guckt mal, wir haben jetzt Leverage, wie man dann sagt, also wir haben einen Hebel, der eben möglicherweise uns mehr Erlöse gibt und dann verkaufen wir es weiter an anderes Private Equity oder an einen anderen, der dafür genug Geld gibt.
Also zweite rechte Periode würde ja gar nicht funktionieren, weil man mindestens acht Jahre drin bleiben muss. Also bis acht Jahre ist Mindestdauer sozusagen und danach kann CVC sich entscheiden, sein Investment abzustoßen. Dabei hat dann aber die DFL immer noch mal ein Rückkaufsrecht.
Also das ist Rückkaufsrecht. Wie sollen sie das finanzieren?
Sie haben sich das Recht eingeräumt. Das muss man dagegen halten. Das haben sie gemacht und davon mal abgesehen. Also das ist auch vom Konzept her ganz anders. Also der Deal läuft ja nach zwanzig Jahren ab. Die einzige Möglichkeit wäre für CVC, wie gesagt, nach acht Jahren das Investment werthaltiger dann weiter zu veräußern. Das ist auch so ungefähr der Rahmen. Acht bis zwölf Jahre, sagt man normalerweise, erhält ein Private Equity sein Investment, dann verkauft man es weiter. Aber ich glaube, ich sehe schon Unterschiede zu klassischen Deals wie Douglas, was jetzt aktuell wieder an die Börse gebracht werden soll. Das ist einfach ein ganz anderes Investment. Man kann es eher vielleicht mit einem Infrastrukturinvestment vergleichen, was die CVC dort macht. Man weiß, dass es nach 20 Jahren erlischt, also schreibt man es über die Zeit sozusagen ab. Es ist nicht im primären Interesse, die DFL oder dieses Investment dort weiter zu veräußern. Wenn man merkt, das ist ein werthaltigeres Investment geworden, wird man darüber nachdenken. Aber ich glaube, man nimmt auch ganz gerne diese Einkommensströme mit, wie Christopher gesagt hat, zur Risikodiversifizierung. Dafür hat man einfach andere Unternehmen im Portfolio, die man dann so 10-Bagger nennt, in den USA oder auf Englisch, die sich vor zehnfachen oder noch mehr vor hundertfachen, das sind andere Unternehmen und nicht das DFL-Investment. Also das würde ich jetzt eher nicht als Szenario sehen.
Christoph hat viel genickt, also ich vermute Zustimmung. Dann lass doch mal darüber sprechen, Christoph. Wer ist den CVC und wie funktioniert so eine Firma? Was machen die?
Na ja, die anderen Finanzmärkten, sagt man oft, das sind Geldsammelstellen. Also ein Beispiel dafür. Das heißt, was bieten die an? Die sagen, wir investieren das Geld, was ihr, die Kunden, dazu gleich noch mehr, uns gebt in Investments. Die nennen das selber alternative Investments, also abseits von der Börse eigentlich. Das heißt, das ist ja so ein Markt wie Unternehmensbeteiligung, Unternehmen übernehmen, schlecht laufende Unternehmen kaufen, besser machen, vielleicht fusionieren, dann weiterverkaufen, das ist das Klassische, was die machen. Aber natürlich mittlerweile auch – ich meine, dieses Sportgeschäft macht ja CVC speziell schon länger, aber das ist ja eine relativ spezielle Asset-Klasse, also eine Anlage-Klasse. Da spezialisieren die sich halt drauf, weil die halt glauben, dass du mit viel – die halten sich natürlich auch für glorreich, also das heißt, die halten sich erstmal für sehr schlau, erstens. Zweitens, die haben natürlich unheimlich viel Kapital, das sie einsammeln. CVC hat, glaube ich, schon gesagt zu 120 Milliarden alleine für dieses Geschäft, was sie da so reinstecken können. Und damit kannst du natürlich schon große Hebel in Bewegung setzen. Also deren Idee ist, sehr nah rein gehen, selber Anteile kaufen, damit man eben mitreden kann und dann eben das Unternehmen, oder ich sage mal das, den Vermögensgegenstand, werthaltiger machen. Jetzt werde ich noch einen Einsatz zu den Kunden, weil das so ein bisschen – ich denke immer, wenn ich die Fans in den Kurven sehe, die Tennisbälle schmeißen. Also ich kann da durchaus mit sympathisieren, ein Stück weiter als Fußballfan. Nur ich weiß nicht, ob das jedem klar ist. Also wenn ich jetzt in der Kurve stehe – ich bin von Köln, FC-Fan seit ich klein bin – wenn da so ein FC-Ultra steht und dann schmeißt man einen Tennisball. So, und der hat jetzt privat vielleicht eine Lebensversicherung. Ich sag mal jetzt mal bei der Allianz. Dann würde ich mal vermuten, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass seine Lebensversicherung über verschiedene Verbindungen auch an der Performance von CVC hängt, nicht ganz klein ist. Das soll heißen, die Allianz ist auch ein großer Geldsammelsteller. Die müssen das Geld ja irgendwo investieren, der Kunden. Und das geben die halt auch zum Teil. Die müssen auch diversifizieren. Die gehen auch an die Börse und die kaufen Anleihen und die kaufen sich bei Firmen ein und so weiter. Aber die geben auch Geld an die Private Equity Konzerne. Das heißt, natürlich wird CVC auch Geld drin haben, von der Allianz zum Beispiel. Also wenn du jetzt klein nimmst, der Ultra aus der Kurve, der Südkurve vom FC zahlt jeden Monat seine 40 Euro für die Lebensversicherung oder seine 70. Und dann haben wir jetzt mal irgendwas gegriffen. Zwei Euro davon gehen eigentlich jeden Monat an CVC, weil die Allianz CVC damit beauftragt, das Kapital zu verwalten oder zu mehren. Damit, wenn der Herr dann, wie man es nen her, Ende seiner Berufslaufbahn in Rente geht und sich die Lebensversicherung auszahlen lässt und er will dann seine Rendite von, ich sag jetzt mal, irgendwas über 30 Jahre von acht oder zehn oder was Prozent da kriegen, dann hat – und der kriegt die, dann verdankt er das ein Stück weit auch CVC möglicherweise.
Hat er aber ja auch nie die Möglichkeit, damit zu entscheiden. Also ich verstehe dein Punkt. Das zeigt quasi, woher die ihr Geld bekommen. Stimmt.
Aber ich wollte damit erklären, dass das alles in hohem Zusammenhang an den Finanzmärkten hat, dass sogar so ganz kleine Kunden wie wir oder der Kollege aus der Südgruppe vom FC möglicherweise auch Kapital bereitstellt dafür, dass CVC bei der DFL einsteigt. Dafür kann er nichts, ist mir klar. Aber ich wollte zum Beispiel sagen, das ist auch Geld. Also diese großen Konzerne, Versicherungskonzerne in den USA sind, die Pensionskassen, die haben unglaubliche Milliarden, die investieren da und genauso wie die Staatsfonds von Saudi-Arabien, Singapur und you name it, die da auch investieren. Und da kommen wir zu dem Punkt, dass die DFL ja glaube ich auch da reingeschrieben hat, oder immer wieder beteuert, ja wir werden mit CVC oder mit dem Investor dann, mit den Partnern dann besprechen, wo kommt das Geld her, dass das nicht aus, ich glaube die haben da irgendwie so ein Passus geschrieben, dass das nicht aus Gegenden kommt, die nicht die Werte, unsere Werte vertreten oder sowas.
Es soll sogar eine Whitelist geben, schreibt die DFL.
Ja, ja so, dann schreibt da so CVC, jawoll, ist so, zack, so. Kannst aber natürlich überhaupt nicht überprüfen, ja. Also ich wüsste nicht, wie das wirklich überzeugen gehen sollte. Das heißt, du bist und bleibst angreifbar, das wird so bleiben. Also das zu dieser Funktion, die die erfüllen und die machen halt was, was in der Form am Kapitalmarkt nicht so viele machen, zumindest nicht auf diesem Niveau. CVC ist so einer der zehn größten PE-Gesellschaften der Welt. Blackstone ist glaube ich noch größer, das sind so die allergrößten. Nur noch eine Klammer dazu kurz, wenn man sich mal die Liste anguckt, dann ist es auch ganz interessant mal zu gucken, welche PE-Gesellschaften sich nicht von dem DFL bemüht haben. Das sind nämlich tendenziell viel mehr, die, die es gemacht haben. Und ich habe mit dem einen oder anderen gesprochen, die haben mir dann gesagt, ja, wir haben das deswegen nicht gemacht, weil uns die Risiken viel zu groß waren. Also Fanproteste, schwierige Governance bei der DFL, andere Worten, können die überhaupt gemeinsam agieren? Und dann die Frage, wie kann ich das über den Laufzeit des Vertrages dann überhaupt sinnvoll – ich will gar nicht sagen, wie Rendite erzielt, sondern überhaupt managen. Weil die beiden Welten sind so weit auseinander, meiner Wahrnehmung, dass es, wenn es dann zum Deal kommt, man hat eine gemeinsame Firma und gemeinsame Gremien mit Leuten, die besetzt sind von Investorenleuten und von DFL-Leuten. Und das Verhältnis wird ja, soll ja so sein, dass die DFL immer das Sagen hat. Die müssen mit einer arbeiten, die müssen sich verstehen, die müssen gegenseitig Verständnis aufbringen für die Bedürfnisse des Partners. Und diese Leute von anderen PIs haben mir gesagt, das sehen wir nicht. Dass man da überhaupt auf einen vernünftigen Nenner kommen kann, dass man mit einer arbeiten kann. Und deswegen haben wir alle die Finger von gelassen. Find ich auch interessant.
Interessanterweise ist es aber auch so, dass PIs sich doch dann grundsätzlich schon für Fußballvereine interessieren. Nicht unbedingt für die DFL, aber für Fußballvereine. Weil dort haben die einfach viel mehr Kreativität, die sie dort auch durchsetzen können. Also ein Problem im Fußball ist ja ganz offensichtlich, dass dort viele ja vielleicht Ex-Profis sitzen, die aber nicht unbedingt Finanzprofis sind. Und da hat ein PI auf jeden Fall ein Hebel zu sagen, wir tauschen das Management aus und setzen dort echte betriebswirtschaftliche Experten ein und schaffen es so, unsere Einkommensströme zu erhöhen, unser Wissen durchzusetzen. Und das ist bei der DFL einfach ganz anders. Also dort sitzt du mit verschiedenen Gremien. Ich glaube, fünf Gremien sollen es da insgesamt werden oder vier oder fünf, mit denen du dich dort irgendwie rumschlagen musst. Und ich glaube, das macht das Ganze einfach viel unattraktiver für einen PI.
Also PI ist natürlich Private Equity. Also eben – Entschuldigung, ja. Ja, ich glaube, das haben die Hörerinnen und Hörer schon verstanden. Ich habe gelesen in der Recherche nochmal, dass es manchmal den Begriff auch Schattenbanken gibt eben für Private Equity-Firmen. Weil eben es ist ein großer Kapitalgeber, aber er ist eben nicht so reguliert wie Banken. Also Basel 3 und so weiter. Da kann man jetzt in die Details reingehen. Jannik, da kann man ja auch sehr kritisch sehen. Und da sind wir ja glaube ich auch schon bei diesem Punkt. Also die DFL, ihr ist es sehr wichtig zu garantieren, dass das Geld eben aus den richtigen Ecken kommt. Und Christoph hat jetzt schon gesagt, na so wirklich garantieren. Können sie das eigentlich gar nicht? Ich meine, wahrscheinlich wird CVC immer auf den europäischen Fond, den er jetzt gerade aufgelegt hat, verweisen, wo die 28 Milliarden jetzt nochmal neu eingeholt wurden. Aber dennoch, die Gesamtfirma wird ja eben auch aus Saudi-Arabien und noch von anderen Ecken finanziert. Ist das denn überhaupt möglich, wenn man diese moralische Ebene überhaupt aufmachen will – und das möchte ja die DFL offenbar, sonst würde sie es nicht auf ihre FAQ-Seite schreiben – ist es denn überhaupt möglich, das zu garantieren? Oder ist das nicht letztlich zwar ein nettes Ansinnen, aber so funktioniert es halt nicht?
Also, ob sie es möchte, will ich mal stark in Zweifel stellen. Ich glaube, sie wird eher dazu getrieben. Aber grundsätzlich gibt es ja viel direktere Einflussmöglichkeiten, die wir auch schon gesehen haben. Also Stichwort, Trikotsponsoring von Qatar Airways auf dem Ärmel von Bayern München. Das ist ein viel direkterer Hebel für, falls Saudi-Arabien wirklich Interesse daran haben sollte, zum Beispiel Sportswashing in der Bundesliga zu betreiben, als über CVC dort Einfluss zu nehmen in der Bundesliga. Es ist auch generell so, man spricht dort von Limited-Partnern und Managing-Partnern. Der Limited-Partner ist immer der Geldgeber, also in diesem Fall, die Kritik bezieht sich ja vor allen Dingen auf diesen PIF, den Saudi-Arabischen Staatsfonds. Und der ist ein so genannten Limited-Partner von CVC, der Managing-Partner. Und üblicherweise ist es so, dass der Limited-Partner eigentlich keiner der Einfluss darauf hat, wie der Managing-Partner mit seinen Beteiligungen umgeht, also wie er das managt. Er hat natürlich einen sehr engen Draht zum Managing-Partner und kann dort Sachen natürlich durchgeben und Interessen bekunden. Aber was der Managing-Partner damit macht, ist immer noch total ihm überlassen. Und man muss dazu ja auch sagen, dass zum Zeitpunkt, also es gibt einen Zeitpunkt, wo man sich committed, also wo man sich auf Deutsch gesagt, wo man sich dazu verständigt, in diesen Fonds einzusteigen und dann fließt das Geld erst später für diesen Fonds. Und zum Zeitpunkt dieses Commitments ist es so, da stand es ja noch gar nicht fest, dass CVC möglicherweise Partner der DFL werden könnte. Also der PIF konnte niemals wissen, dass die DFL dort einen Investor an Bord holen sollte. Und das kann man dann auch niemals im Fonds werfen, dass Saudi-Arabien irgendwie jetzt so eine groß angelegte Aktion im Hintergrund gestartet hat, in den Bundesliga Einfluss zu nehmen. Weil es ist schon ein paar Jahre jetzt her, dass dieser Fonds aufgesetzt wurde. Und insofern, das würde ich jetzt – also diese Kritik verstehe ich nicht und ich verstehe wirklich viele der Kritikpunkte. Ich bin auch als HSV-Fan an des Traditionsvereins und leide dort mit. Ja, ich verstehe sehr viele dieser Kritikpunkte und ich emotionalisiere mich da auch sehr mit den Fans. Aber diesen Punkt mit Saudi-Arabien verstehe ich wirklich nicht.
Ja, gut, ich meine, du unterstellst jetzt eine Intention. Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, das ist den Fans gar nicht wichtig. Ich glaube, Saudi-Arabien ist halt quasi neben Katar der Zweite, der versucht, mit aller Macht, sich Sport zu kaufen und eben darüber sein neues Geschäftsmodell, also sein Geschäftsmodell zu transformieren. Und das wie der Streb-Fans, weil man eben gesehen hat, dann findet eine WM eben in einem Wüstenstart statt. Und jetzt findet die nächste WM da und der DFB-Präsident spricht jetzt schon davon, ja, die haben ja eine Fußballkultur und so weiter, also spricht exakt dasselbe passiert wieder. Und die Fans sind dagegen. Und dann geht es einfach nur darum, mit denen wollen wir nichts zu tun haben. Und dass das so in der Finanzwelt kaum geht, weil quasi bei VW auch Katar drin hängt und so weiter, das ist ja da. Aber sie unterstellen jetzt glaube ich nicht die Intention, hey, Saudi-Arabien will sich hier rein sneaken durch die Hintertür, sondern sie sagen einfach, hey, wir wollen bei diesem Spiel nicht mitspielen, zu dem eben dann auch jemand wie Saudi-Arabien gehört.
Absolut, darum geht es ja auch glaube ich gar nicht, sondern es geht eher darum, dass man dieses Vehikel CVC als verlängerte Arm Saudi-Arabiens, das gab es in den Kurven schon auch als transparente und das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht. Also dass Saudi-Arabien Einfluss nimmt oder Katar oder wer auch immer, mit komischsten menschlichen Ansichten in den Sport hinein, um da dann einen eigenen Interesse durchzusetzen, das steht ja außer Frage und das kritisiere ich auch genauso. Aber dieses Vehikel, das verstehe ich dann in dem Punkt nicht. Man könnte jetzt auch sagen, um nochmal dieses Beispiel des FC-Fans aufzunehmen, dann dürfte ja auch kein Hyundai zum Beispiel fahren, weil der PIV einen Werk mit Hyundai in Saudi-Arabien gebaut hat. Das könnte man ewig lang weiterführen.
Ich verstehe deinen Punkt, aber der Theorie nach darf man dann nicht mehr atmen, weil man dann ein Molekül atmet, das Adolf Hitler schon mal in der Lunge hatte. Das ist sogar wissenschaftlich korrekt, so könnte methodisch inkorrekt zuhören. Aber dann lasst mal hören, ich möchte nochmal den ganzen O-Ton spielen, den wir im Intro nur kurz angespielt haben von eben Alexander DiBelius, wo er eben erklärt, was macht er eigentlich. Er erklärt das in einem anderen Zusammenhang. Er erzählt nämlich, wie er quasi seine persönlichen Finanzen weiterentwickelt hat und dabei immer mehr ins Risiko gegangen ist. Und nebenher erklärt er aber, was er eigentlich gerade macht. Und das war sehr eindrücklich. Deswegen hören wir uns das mal kurz an und gleichen es dann ab mit – was könnte das für die DFL heißen?
Jetzt kaufe ich Unternehmen. Also zum Beispiel Douglas, das kennen sie Typico, Messerindustriegase, Breitling. Deswegen musste ich eine Breitling-Uhr auch tragen. Hatten gehört uns oder habe ich gekauft. Und da bin ich jetzt direkt beteiligt sozusagen. Kaufen wir, behalten wir dann vier bis fünf Jahre, drei Jahre, vier Jahre, sieben Jahre, je nachdem. Versuchen, from good to great, also ein gutes Unternehmen, zu einem noch besseren zu machen und dann zu mehr Geld zu verkaufen. Und an dem Capital Gain, da bin ich dann unmittelbar beteiligt. Das ist letzten Endes Private Equity. Private Equity ist immer Ownership off-site, Unternehmen kaufen, hoffentlich zu einem vernünftigen Geld, besser machen entlang aller Dimensionen, also von der Kapitalstruktur über Umsatz, Kosten, Marktpositionierung, Strategien, from strategy to tactics sag ich immer, und dann hoffentlich bei einem Exit eben wieder verkaufen und dann aus dem Mehrwert geht das Geld teilweise zurück an uns Investoren, aber der Carry ist sozusagen ein Teil des Mehrwerts, das sie geschafft haben. Das sind 20% des Mehrwerts, die bleiben sozusagen dann bei CVC hängen und davon kriege ich unmittelbar direkt an meinen Transaktionen beteiligt, kriege ich halt dann wieder einen kleinen Schnitt, aber das ernährt sein Mann, das ist ganz gut.
Da sind wir natürlich beruhigt, dass er genügend Geld verdient. Ja, das ist mir generell sehr aufgefallen. Ich habe sehr auch viel Weltwirtschaftsforum und so weiter in Davos gesehen. Keine Angst, ich habe keine Tone davon mitgebracht, aber immer wieder zu betonen, dass man ja ganz gut über die Runden kommt, aber immer mit dem Na, ich kann meine Miete davon zahlen. Vielleicht rege ich da ein bisschen allergisch drauf, weil ich in der teuersten Stadt Deutschlands lebe, aber gut. Das ist aber ein anderer Punkt, aber was ich interessant fand, Christoph, war also zum einen natürlich die verschiedenen Unternehmen, an denen man beteiligt ist und wir haben jetzt ja zwar schon klar gemacht, die Beteiligung an der DFL wäre von ihrer Art her anders, aber dennoch scheint mir ja das ganze Denken von Private Equity darauf hin zu basieren, dass man eben das macht, was er zwischendurch auch genannt hat, also Kosten senken, Organisationen straffen, auch die Art und Weise der Kapitalstruktur ist extrem wichtig und dann gibt es eben einen Exitpunkt und eigentlich ist es für die Diskussion jetzt dann gar nicht wichtig, will man dann innerhalb der Zeit raus oder nach den 20 Jahren erlischt das, das ist dann der vordefinierte Exitpunkt. Aber das ist ja sehr viel im Doing, wie ich jetzt gelernt habe, was man sagen muss, also sprich im operativen Geschäft, aber da kommt man ja eigentlich gar nicht rein bei der DFL, zumindest angeblich.
Naja, für diese gemeinsame Firma, die dann die Medienrechte besser vermarkten soll, wird natürlich gemeinsam gemanagt. Das ist ja auch, das geht ja auch überall. Das ist ja auch für die DFL ein Teil der Attraktivität, weil die nämlich ein Know-how bekommen, was sie so möglicherweise nicht haben oder an das sie schwer rankommen. Weil wenn der Investor oder wenn der Partner dann drin ist, dann haben die genug Erfahrung oder zumindest tun die so – ich traue denen schon zu – dass die wissen, was für Leute brauche ich dann. Wie muss ich das aufstellen? Ich glaube nicht, dass es darum geht, dass die – das heißt, das wird nicht funktionieren, die werden nicht irgendwie in die Liga eingreifen und sagen, ihr müsst es aber hier anders wirtschaften und eure anders verteilen und so weiter. Und ihr müsst da in den Clubs für besseres, für mehr Sparen sorgen. Das ist nicht der Punkt. Das ist ja auch nicht angedacht. Aber in der Firma, die man dann gemeinsam hat, auch wenn ihr DFL 90 Prozent hat, setzen die schon auch drauf. Die Befürworter in der DFL, dass die sagen, da haben wir einen Partner, der uns relativ schnell Sachen zeigen kann. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, beibringen, das klingt ein bisschen so von oben herab, aber Sachen zeigen kann und der über Netzwerke verfügt, um Know-how zu aktivieren, was wir so in der Geschwindigkeit und mit der Qualität nicht selber mobilisieren könnten. Ich sage mal ein Beispiel. Ich hatte mal mit einem Klubschef gesprochen, schon einige Jahre her, der mal einen Private Equity Investor für einige Zeit hatte. Ich sage jetzt nicht, wo das war, weil das war ein vertrauliches Gespräch, aber er hat dann gesagt, ja, was haben wir da gelernt? Also das war ein relativ kleines Investment, aber von einer sehr großen Gesellschaft. Und die haben dann gesagt, ja, hier, also dann gab es ein Problem im Club, wo die sich nicht erklären konnten, wie man wieder stand. Und dann hat der Investor gesagt, und der Investor, in dem Moment war wirklich ein Investor, und der einen kleinen Anteil hatte, gesagt, pass auf, wir sind beteiligt an einer Firma, die euch da helfen kann, die ist in den USA, wir rufen die mal an. Drei Tage später waren von der Firma zehn Mann bei diesem Club und haben gesagt, hier, der Investor hat gesagt, wir sollen mal bei euch gucken kommen, wir helfen euch dabei. Hat die Firma nichts gekostet, hat den Club nichts gekostet und die haben denen sehr geholfen, bestimmte Dinge im Club neu aufzustellen. Und warum? Weil der Investor Interesse daran hat, dass es der Firma seinem Investment besser geht und weil der sehr schnell Ressourcen mobilisieren konnte, was du wahrscheinlich, wenn du jetzt einfach mal angefangen hast, hänge ich mal ans Telefon und guck mal, wen es denn so gibt und ruf mal den Berater an, wahrscheinlich Monate gebraucht. Ist jetzt vielleicht verklärt, aber ein Beispiel dafür, was diese Firmen auch mitbringen können auf diesem Netzwerk und das erhoffen die sich. Natürlich werden die auch ihre Meinung sagen zu bestimmten Sachen, das ist ganz klar. Ich will aber vielleicht, wenn ich darf, noch einen Punkt, ich würde es mal ganz kurz rumdrehen. Es gibt ja in der DFL durchaus Leute, die dafür sind. Man vergisst das immer so ein bisschen bei der ganzen Opposition. Es gibt ja Leute, die sagen, wir wollen das, wir wollen die Partnerschaft. Sonst hätten wir ja keine ein paar Drittel Mehrheit bekommen im ersten Schritt unter all den Bedingungen, die wir alle kennen. Und warum sagen die, dass sie das wollen? Das Offensichtliche ist, diese Medienvermarkten zu verbessern und so weiter. Das ist alles geschenkt, was offensichtlich gesagt wurde. Was die auch sagen ist, wir wollen das, weil wir glauben, dass das ganze Management professionalisieren kann, wir viel lernen können mit diesen Leuten dank dieser Leute, wenn man auf ein gemeinsames Niveau kommt oder ein gemeinsames Verständnis kommt, plus die sagen auch, weil du sagtest gerade, was ja so ein Punkt ist, die immer die Kosten drücken. Jetzt frag mal den üblichen Klubschef, was sind die Kosten, die ihn am meisten nerven? Dann kommt ganz schnell das Thema Berater. Unmengen, die an die Berater fließen. Natürlich sind die Spieler also teuer, ist auch klar, aber das ist ein anderer Punkt. Was gibt es seit langem schon? Es gibt ja diese Verhandlungen bei UEFA und Diskussionen und bei der ECA. Wie kann man diesen Berater-Wahnsinn irgendwie deckeln? Bisher ist das alles im Sande verlaufen. Es gibt ja auch Klagen und es ist alles sehr kompliziert. Aber die Leute, die in der DFL für die Partnerschaft sind, denken sich auch, wenn ich dann so einen Partner habe, auch wenn er nur 8 Prozent hat, was meinst du, was die für Räder drehen können, wenn die richtig wollen und sagen, pass mal auf, wir gucken jetzt mal hier rein, sagen, wo der Berater ist, aber echt teuer. Und wir sehen nicht den Mehrwert, was ja viele Clubs genauso sehen, du musst ja auch zahmabe zahlen, das ist gar nicht furchtbar. Wer weiß, ob die nicht helfen können, weil die noch woanders drin sind, dass man diese Diskussion, diesen Beratermarkt zu regulieren, mehr Schwung rein kriegt. Nur so ein Beispiel. Und das wäre aus der PE. Sicht, aus der Private Equity Sicht gedacht, die sehen da einen Kostenfaktor, wo die sagen, wir würden versuchen, den mal irgendwie zu deckeln, um es den Clubs betriebswirtschaftlich leichter zu machen. Ob das klappen wird, ist eine andere Frage. Aber das ist doch ein Punkt.
Müsste ja das PE eigentlich auch beim Club rein. Also wir sind ja eigentlich gerade bei der Beteiligung an den Medien.
Jaja, aber ich sage jetzt nur, das sind so Sachen, denn die gucken sich ja das Gesamte dann an. Ja, wenn die in die Clubs einmischen, können sie gar nicht. Aber dass die dann hingehen und den Liegen auch bei sowas unter Umständen helfen, schlägt das nicht aus, dass die das unter Umständen versuchen oder dass die das auch viele sind, das wollen.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Also ich verstehe, dass sich die Club-Chefs erhoffen, dass es da Synergieeffekte gibt. Aber wir reden ja hier über eine Erlösbeteiligung an die Medienerlösen. CVC und die sind ja sehr gut darin, effizient mit ihrer Zeit und ihren Ressourcen umzugehen. Die haben doch gar kein Interesse daran, dass Berater Honorare sind. Die wollen einfach nur, dass das Produkt besser vermarktet wird. Vielleicht sagen sie dann irgendwann auch mal – und das ist ja ein Grundproblem, das Produkt ist halt scheiße, deswegen verkauft es sich ja im Ausland so schlecht – vielleicht kommt CVC darauf – aber wenn ich dann auf sowas gucke, dann verstehe ich zum Beispiel nicht, die DFL, alle Bilder werden produziert von Sportcars. Und wir alle sind uns, glaube ich, einig, da müssten sich Dinge verändern. Und was macht die DFL noch bevor der Investor einsteigt, noch bevor die nächste TV-Rechtevergabe entschieden wird? Sie verlängert den Vertrag mit dem Geschäftsführer Josef Jupp Nehl, ehemaliger Bundesligaspieler, der das seit 2008 hauptverantwortet. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass der einen schlechten Job macht, aber das ist doch ein komisches Signal nach außen, wenn man sagt, wir wollen uns verändern, wir wollen innovativer werden und wir müssen auch ans Produkt ran und dann macht man das, bevor jemand mitreden kann.
Noch ein Satz zum Jannik. Das Beraterthema war nur ein Beispiel, wie die auf das Gesamtprodukt gucken. Und man hofft, dass man sich da – und ich will da gar nicht behaupten, dass sie sich jetzt zu UEFA geht und sagt, wir müssen die Beraterdeckel haben. Aber die kriegen dann Know-how, wie man so etwas besser anstellen kann. Und natürlich gewinnt die ganze Liga – wenn ich das jetzt von oben betrachte – wenn die weniger Geld für Berater ausgeben, haben die natürlich für andere Dinge mehr Geld. Potenziell wird das Produkt dann besser. Und dann steigt die Wertehaltigkeit der Medienrechte. Also die denken schon ganzheitlich. Das wollte ich damit sagen. Mir ist klar, dass die sich einig sind. Ich wollte nur als Beispiel nehmen. Weil das so ein klassisches Beispiel ist, wenn du die Klubschefs fragst, was kotzt euch am meisten an in eurer G&V, wo ihr das meiste Geld für – also in der Gewinn- und Versuchsrechnung, wo ihr das meiste Geld für ausgeben müsst, dann kommt das immer zuerst. Die beraten, die saugen aus. Sie sind ja auch selber schuld, weil sie sich darauf einlassen, aber das wäre so ein Beispiel, wo das passieren könnte. Aber klar, was das andere angeht, geht natürlich um das Produkt und ich habe da auch gelächelt, als ich das gesehen habe mit der Vertragsverlängerung.
Also am Produkt bzw. beim Aufbau dieser Plattform, da soll ja auch vor allen Dingen diese Energie entstehen. Also Beispiel Douglas kennt sich sehr gut, also CVC Investment Douglas, kennt sich sehr gut mit der Vermarktung aus und wie man eine Plattform baut, wie man Kunden gewinnt. Und da kann die Bundesliga von lernen, möglicherweise. Und das wäre immer noch innerhalb dieser Chinese Walls, weil es ein deutsches Investment ist, so wird es jetzt zumindest verkauft. Jetzt kann man davon halten, was man will, aber ich glaube, darum geht es und da kann man auch, glaube ich, Kostendisziplin einhalten. Da kann ein Private Equity drauf gucken und sagen, hey, diese Ausgabe ist unnötig. Da kann man sparen. Ja, und ich glaube, also an dieser Plattform kann ein Private Equity am ehesten einen guten Einfluss nehmen.
Ich würde sagen, wenn du jetzt schon Douglas hier mit reinbringst, dann spiele ich mal kurz den Ton von Tina Müller. Das ist jetzt aus dem Hi Podcast. Der erzählt sie nämlich über die Erwartung von CVC und dann ganz interessant, und da wird mich dann deine Einschätzung zu interessieren, Jannik, die Geschwindigkeit, mit der man dann auch Veränderungen anstößt. Zumindest ich habe da so leichte Bauchschmerzen, wenn ich das neben die DFL halte, wie ich sie bisher kenne.
Was müssen Sie den Private-Equity-Investoren versprechen, um das Geld zu bekommen? Was sind die Wertsteigerungsraten? Das sind die berühmten Verdopplungen alle zwei Jahre, Vervierfachungen in vier Jahren. Ist das das, was Sie sagen müssen?
Also um es mal ein bisschen theoretisch zu formulieren, solche Initiativen besprechen wir anhand eines Businessplans und da schauen wir uns an. Und dann entscheiden wir und weiter in irgendwelche konkreten Zahlen werde ich jetzt auch nicht gehen.
Aber schon sportlich, was man sich vornimmt?
Ja, mit Private Equity zu arbeiten ist sportlich, aber das ist es ja gerade, was es so toll macht, weil man eben schnell nach vorne denken kann und schnell unternehmen kann, weil Unternehmen oder Unternehmertum kommt ja von etwas unternehmen und man die Hebel eben schnell umlegen kann.
Schnelle Hebe, die umgelegt werden können. Übrigens so schnell, Tina Müller ist jetzt gar nicht mehr CEO von Douglas, die ist zu VLeda gewechselt. Wir müssen auch gleich nochmal über die Schuldenstruktur von Douglas reden, da habe ich nämlich auch noch eine Anschlussfrage in Bezug auf CVC. Aber wenn du das ebenso hörst, Jannik, hohe Erwartung ist ja klar, hat ja die DFL an sich selbst auch, aber dann auch ein hohes Tempo in der Umsetzung. Glaubst du, das kann funktionieren?
Es kann zumindest nicht schaden. Ich glaube, da sind die Strukturen so verkrustet, dass ein bisschen Tempo ja gar nicht mal schaden würde, wie gesagt. Also, ob es funktionieren kann, ich glaube, es muss funktionieren. Also, das ist der Anspruch eines private Accruities und ich glaube, da sind sich auch alle einig, wenn du so jemanden an Bord holst, dann musst du dieses Tempo auch mitgehen. Und ob das dann klappt, das ist eine ganz andere Frage, das steht auf einem ganz anderen Papier. Aber, ja, ich glaube, alle sind sich darüber einig, dass das der Anspruch ist und dass man sich darauf dann verständigt, wenn man diesen an Bord holt.
Und Christoph, glaubst du, die DFL kriegt das hin, wenn jetzt schon – also, wir haben ja vorhin darüber gesprochen, andere private equity Firmen haben gesagt, die DFL ist kein guter Partner. Und auch deswegen hat sich wahrscheinlich Blackstone zurückgezogen. Das würde ja auch jetzt nicht dafür sprechen, dass man sich dann in der Mediaco, man überlegt sich dann, wie wollen wir die OTT-Platform machen, welchen Content wollen wir für die digitalen Kanäle? Und dann sagen alle 36 Profiklubs, sagen, mega geil, danke, dass ihr damit kommt. Wir haben nämlich gestern schon jemand eingestellt, der das macht. Und morgen habt ihr die ersten Ergebnisse. Ganz so funktioniert es ja nicht in der DFL.
Also wenn ich da schnell höre, was die Frau Müller da gesagt hat, dann passt das eigentlich diametral nicht zur DFL, sage ich jetzt mal. Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen gemein. Ich halte das für sehr schwierig dann in der Zusammenarbeit, dass das funktionieren kann. Ich glaube auch, dass, also wenn wir, Frau Manager Marketing, wir machen ja viele Geschichten über Unternehmen, Vermieterunternehmen oder andere Unternehmen. Und oft ist der Angriffspunkt unser Angriffspunkt, weil wir glauben, dass die Governance nicht funktioniert. Also die Gremien, die du hast, die funktionieren entweder nicht, weil die Leute nicht miteinander klagen oder weil die Gremienstruktur, das hast du bei Vermieterunternehmen, des bei sehr großen sehr oft, sich gegenseitig blockieren. Und da ist die DFL meiner Meinung nach ein klassisches Beispiel. Also wenn wir jetzt eine DFL-Geschichte machen würden, dann würde man erst mal sagen, die Governance kann so eigentlich funktionieren. Mir ist klar, dass die DFL ein sehr besonderes Unternehmen ist durch die Struktur. Aber du bekommst ja immer sehr, sehr große, immer größere Fliehkräfte, desto weiter die Interessen der einzelnen Stakeholder, wie man so schön sagt, der einzelne Mitglieder in dem Fall bei der DFL auseinandergehen. Und die Interessen der Groß- und der Kleinklubs, erst mal solop gesagt, sind halt mittlerweile so dermaßen unterschiedlich geworden, dass es für die DFL so extrem schwierig ist, geschlossen aufzutreten und immer Kompromisse machen. Kompromisse musst du immer machen, aber wenn natürlich – das ist ja kein neues Argument, zum Beispiel der großen Klubs Bayern, Dortmund usw. die sagen, naja, ein Großteil der Werthaltigkeit der Deutschen, der Bundesliga besteht darin, dass wir da mitspielen. Und nicht, dass Eintracht Braunschweig mitspielt oder Erzgebirge Aue oder so. Da ist ja auch was dran. Also wenn ich jetzt versuche, in Asien Augsburg gegen Heidenheim zu vermarkten im Gegensatz zu Bayern gegen Dortmund, dann ist natürlich klar, was dabei rauskommt. Die haben schon einen Punkt. Und ich meine, es gibt ja nicht wenige, die schon länger sagen, eigentlich müsste die Bundesliga auch diesen Schritt vorziehen, den andere Ligen auch schon gemacht haben, dass man eben die Liga-Verband aufteilt. Also trennt praktisch in Erste und Zweite Liga zumindest – und selbst wenn man das jetzt mal theoretisch durchdenkt, selbst die Erste Liga, wenn die jetzt einen Eigenverband nur noch hätte, mit 18, dann haben wir mal DFL 1 sozusagen, oder DFL Erste Liga, dann hast du selbst da Unterschiede, hast du jetzt aktuell dann Heidenheim und Bayern oder Bochum und Bayern. Allein da sind die Unterschiede schon so riesig, dass selbst das schon schwierig wäre, in Gemeinschaftssicht zu kommen. Jetzt mal unabhängig von den ganzen Fragen Solidarität und was die DFL an die anderen abgibt, alles geschenkt. Das heißt, um eine Partnerschaft wie mit diesen Private-Equity-Typen, die genau wissen, was sie wollen, die, wie Frau Müller sagt, die machen Druck, Druck, Druck, schnell, schnell, schnell. Aber die machen es auch, wie ich jetzt nicht sage, per se immer nur schlecht. Manchmal ist Druck ja auch gut, damit man was geschafft kriegt. Aber um das im Sinne des Fußballs auch zu nutzen, also die Chancen zu ergreifen, die das auch bietet, ohne Frage, und die viele Manager ja auch sehen, musst du auf Seiten des Fußballs auch wirklich handlungsfähig sein, einigermaßen geschlossen auftreten, auch um dich nicht über den Tisch ziehen zu lassen von Herrn DeBelius in Zukunft oder so. Weil die schon natürlich auch gucken auf ihren Vorteil. Das ist halt ein Investor und Punkt. Und da bin ich skeptisch, ob die DFL das hinkriegt. Und es gibt auch Leute, die dir dann sagen, die dafür sind, die würden das öffentlich nicht sagen, aber die sagen dir dann ja, wir hoffen ja darauf, dass wenn dann die Partnerschaft kommt, dann entsteht so ein Sog und mehr Klubs verstehen, dass sie da jetzt mitziehen müssen. Sonst haben wir nichts davon so ungefähr. Und dann hast du so zu ahnen, wenn du bist jetzt zu feige, sag jetzt mal, oder du bist zu bang, um die Revolution von innen anzustoßen, ob es jetzt nur eine Trennung ist oder eine Neuverhandlung der Beziehungen, da gibt es untereinander, wie auch immer man das jetzt nennen will. Und das kommt dann so indirekt rein, weil da kommt dann der Investor und der schüttelt jetzt den Baum und plötzlich sagen alle möglichen Leute, oh, wir müssen wirklich was ändern, weil sonst sind wir nicht in der Lage, das zu nutzen. Ich finde, das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, der so unterschwellig ist, dass eigentlich alle wissen oder viele wissen, die DFL ist extrem schwer zu führen, extrem schwer als Organisation zusammenzuhalten. Und jetzt kommt der Partner und wenn du mit dem Partner klarkommen willst, nicht nur klarkommen, sondern auch davon was haben willst, dann musst du dich zusammenraufen. Und wenn ich das schon nicht aus meinen eigenen Interessen heraus hinkriege, dann mache ich das über diese Partnerschaft, weil die uns dann zwingt. Das ist vielleicht naiv, vielleicht führt es eher zum Gegenteil. Die Fliehkräfte nehmen noch stärker zu und der Mann fliegt ja auseinander. Aber das Argument ist durchaus wichtig für einige, aus meiner Wahrnehmung, weil die sagen, das könnte sozusagen der, wie soll ich sagen, der zweit, also fast der wichtigere Gewinn für die DFL sein, weil die uns zur Einheit zwingt.
Ja, oder halt zum Aufkunden der Solidargemeinschaft, womit dann die Fans noch mehr Grund hätten, dagegen zu protestieren.
Ja, aber die Frage ist ja auch, wie man das dann, man kann sich ja auch andere Modelle vorstellen, aber es ist echt schwierig, weil du hast eine gewachsene Tradition, du hast sehr, sehr, sehr unterschiedliche, ich sag jetzt mal einfach Unternehmen, sechs Unternehmen, die ganz unterschiedlichen Blickwinkel haben. Manche denken global, machen Büros in Shanghai auf, und andere denken an bis zum drittnächsten Dorf, weil das ist nämlich deren Einzugsgebiet und denen ist egal, was in Asien passiert. Und die arbeiten zusammen und die sind aufeinander angewiesen.
Und du wolltest auch eine Zwei-Drittel-Mehrheit.
Nein, nein, alles klar, ich red jetzt nur so ins Blaue rein, aber dass das nicht so funktionieren kann oder sehr schlecht funktioniert auf Dauer ist eigentlich offensichtlich. Und durch den Deal könnte, wenn er dann zustande kommt, ein Druck entstehen, darüber nochmal neu nachzudenken. Wie das aussehen kann – ich bin ja nicht Herr Merkel, Herr Lenz oder Herr Watzfeld zum Glück, muss nicht mit denen tauschen – das ist Hölle, höllisch schwierig. Aber die Diskussion, die läuft und die Fragen stehen im Raum und die werden eher noch lauter oder noch deutlicher herausstehen, wenn du dann einen Partner hast, weil der wird dir die Fragen ständig stellen.
Ja genau und ich meine positiv formuliert könnte man auch sagen, vielleicht kommen sie dann über den Partner endlich mal darauf, dass das Produkt halt schlecht ist und das dafür auch eine andere, also dass es vielleicht ein Problem ist, dass die Unternehmen so unterschiedliche Umsätze haben, dass die logischerweise ganz anderes Marktverständnis und so weiter haben. Aber eben es kann auch sein, dass dann über ein Partner eben es genau zu dieser Abspaltung kommt und weil der Partner muss sich ja auch absichern. CVC hat das in La Liga als Problem, dass da nämlich vier Vereine gesagt haben, wir stimmen diesem Deal, der über 50 Jahre läuft, stimmen wir nicht zu, weil wir einzeln vermarktet viel besser sind. Das ist überhaupt krass. 50 Jahre, also das ist, kann man ja noch mal nachgucken, was Chicago mit seinen Parkgebühren gemacht hat. Gibt es sehr, sehr schöne Videos.
Wobei ich da noch eine Unterscheidung vornehmen würde, also nicht das Produkt ist schlecht, sondern das Medienprodukt ist schlecht. Das ist mir dann schon irgendwie wichtig.
Ja, wobei vielleicht ist auch das Produkt nicht mehr ganz so gut, wie man gedacht hat, weil eben du hast eben nicht mehr über den vollen Start geht.
Aber für diesen Fall des Investors ist es nicht so wichtig. Also der Investor interessiert sich ja für das Medienprodukt.
Ja genau, aber das Medienprodukt wird doch gestaltet durch das Produkt vor Ort. Und wenn ich NFL oder andere US-Sportübertragungen sehe und da ist die Stadion nicht voll, dann fällt es mir immer auf.
NFL wird nicht voll sein, aber ja.
Gut, bei den letzten Spielen war es dann doch durchaus so. Und oft im vierten Viertel. Aber genau, bei der Bundesliga hast du zum Anpfiff schon viele halbvolle Stadien. Und was signalisiert das nach außen? Also du erzählst, es ist Unterhaltungsindustrie. Wir müssen hier so tun, als ob jedes Spiel das Allerwichtigste des Planeten wäre und dass man auch unbedingt verfolgen muss. Wie jetzt – es tut mir leid, dass ich immer diese Teams nenne, aber es sind halt die Hoffenheim gegen Wolfsburg. Im Ausland musst du als Medienbetrieb so tun, als ob das das wichtigste Spiel der Welt wäre. Und das machen die auch in ihrer Übertragung. Mensch, jetzt der große Clash in the Wolves, Meeting finally with the Krichgrow. Brazilianer, ja gut, das sagen sie jetzt nicht. Aber ich gucke ja viel über ESPN und so weiter. Und dann schalten die ins Stadion und du siehst, da sitzen drei Leute auf Höhe der Mittellinie. Also jetzt übertrieben gesagt. Das ist natürlich schon ein Riesenproblem.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Deswegen, mein Plädoyer ist auch den Relegationsplatz durch einen Traditionsplatz erschaffen zu ersetzen. Aber da komme ich nicht weit mit.
Jetzt versucht er sich so reinzusnicken.
Es ist genauso unfair wie ein Relegationsplatz, aber es wird zumindest zu einer Umverteilung von Traditionsteams in die erste Liga führen. Naja, aber ich weiß, dass ich damit nicht durchkomme.
Ich meine, es ist ja klar. Ich darf noch einen Satz sagen, wenn wir jetzt davon sprechen. Das hat ja die DFL immer ausgeschlossen, aber jetzt für den strategischen Prozess. Aber diese Fragen, ob man vielleicht an den Modus was ändern muss, ob man vielleicht an der Liga stammt, sind ja schon seit Jahren gestellt. Also Wolfgang Holzhäuser, ewig bei Bayer Leverkunft, der hat schon vor 50 Jahren gesagt, Leute, denkt mal über Playoffs nach. Wenn ihr euch darüber aufregt, dass die Bayern immer gewinnen, wenn du am Ende wieder am Eishock die letzten acht in Playoffs schickst, dann ist die Chance natürlich größer, dass die Bayern auch mal auf die Nase fliegen und dann holen die vielleicht in der Saison zwar 100 Punkte, aber verlieren dann im Halbfinale gegen Frankfurt oder so, wie ja auch schon mal hin und wieder im Pokalfinale passiert oder in einzelnen Spielen. Das heißt, das ist ein neuer Kick. Das kannst du auch wieder ganz anders. Da kommen wir jetzt auch im Ausland vermarkten, weil das dann einfach in den letzten vier, sechs Wochen der Saison einfach total spannend nochmal würde. Widerspricht der Tradition, weiß ich alles. Widerspricht dem Verständnis, wie die Liga funktionieren soll. Aber die Diskussion ist ja nicht neu. Und wenn du den Nebelius fragen würdest, wie willst du dir das denn alles so vorstellen? Der würde wahrscheinlich sagen, naja, erstmal Liga anders zusammensetzen. Heidenheim raus, Augsburg raus, dafür Schalke, HSV natürlich alle rein, Kaiserslautern, erste Liga, aber das sind die riesengroßen Marken. Die gehören da rein, so wie das in den USA mit den Franchises ist. Können wir nicht kopieren, ich sag's nur. Und dann am besten noch Playoffs. Und das knallt richtig rein. Klar, wird nicht kommen, wissen wir. Aber die Diskussion geht jetzt so zu tun, als wenn das jetzt über den Investor diese Fragen drohen oder die Spieltage auf, das haben wir ja auch alles schon länger diskutiert. Das ist ein bisschen Augenwischerei, weil die Fragen liegen ja auf der Straße. Und die gibt's ja schon viel länger.
Die muss man sich auch unabhängig von einem Investor stellen.
Die sind sowieso im Raum. Und auch die Frage, wie ich das moderner inszeniere. Wir haben ja das Problem mit den leeren Stadien. Habt ihr beide angesprochen? Kenn ich auch. Die haben ja Angst, massiv Angst, dass ihnen die ganzen jungen Leute abhanden kommen. Ist ja schon der Fall. Dann hast du teilweise keinen richtigen Handyanfang im Stadion. Wenn der Stadion nur halb voll ist, bricht alles zusammen. Katastrophe. Die Leute gucken anders heute. Und wenn du die gewinnen willst, die Angst ist ja groß in der Liga, dass du die alle verlierst. Und möglicherweise ist da so ein frischer Blick schon ganz gut. Wenn du es anders inszenieren willst. Nur die Frage ist, das reizt natürlich an den Traditionen. Mal sehen, wie das wird. Aber da müssen die ran. Und das ist auch unabhängig vom strategischen Investor der Fall. Da müssen die ran, sonst würden die weglaufen. Wenn du das nicht zu einem umfassenderen, moderneren, cooleren Produkt umarbeitest oder weiterentwickelst, was eben auch dann diese Zuschauer anzieht, ob nun vor dem Bildschirm oder auch im Stadion, die du erreichen willst, damit es auf Dauer die große Popularität erhalten bleibt.
Aber da sind wir doch schon beim berühmten Punkt rote Linien. Und ehrlich gesagt, ganz viel von dem, was ihr jetzt gesagt habt, klingt nicht so, als ob für CVC das überhaupt nur erträglich sein könnte, sich an diese roten Linien zu halten, weil dann dürften sie eben gar nicht mitreden, bei Spielplan-Gestaltung, bei Anpfiff, bei Modus und so weiter und sofort. Und es gibt ja schon einen Unterschied, ob über den Druck eines Investors diese Themen angegangen werden oder ob sie einfach so angegangen werden. Denn einfach so würde bedeuten, bei den Mitglieder geführten Vereinen, da haben die Fußballfans noch ein Mitspracherecht und darauf weisen sie ja letztlich mit den Protesten aktuell gerade hin. Und das kann man ja auch tatsächlich nicht wegdiskutieren, dass das eine andere Qualität hat, als wenn eben das über CVC kommt. Deswegen die erste Frage, Jannik, kannst du dir überhaupt vorstellen, dass diese roten Linien, selbst wenn sie schriftlich fixiert sind – und ich weiß, liebe DFL, dass es so ist und so weiter, habt ihr ganz toll in eurem FAQ erklärt – aber die können sich doch da gar nicht dran halten, weil sie müssen ja ans Produkt ran.
Also wie genau diese roten Linien aussehen, steht ja auch noch gar nicht fest. Also die Verträge sind ja nicht offen gelegt, deswegen kann man da auch nur ein bisschen spekulieren.
Obwohl alles so transparent ist. Komisch, oder?
Naja, man hätte also dieses 15-seitige Dokument ist ja immerhin da, von der DFL. Das muss man herlassen, auch wenn sich dann Steffen Merkel, glaube ich, selbst in der Süddeutschen beklagt hat, dass das ja alles furchtbar kompliziert in der Kommunikation sei. Einerseits, wenn es zu lang ist, zu kompliziert, wenn es zu kurz ist, ist es nicht ausführlich genug. Richtig. Also abgesehen davon, ich habe auch mit einem Investor gesprochen und ihm genau diese Frage gestellt und er sagte, nie im Leben gibt man eine Milliarde Euro und vertraut dann darauf, dass die anderen das gut machen. Also es wird immer das Interesse geben, mit am Tisch zu sitzen, ob man dann in diese Entscheidung, wiefern man da Einfluss hat, das muss man mal schauen. Aber wo man vielleicht darauf achten müsste, ist jetzt bei der Gremien-Sitzung. Es soll ja vier Instanzen geben, also das Management, den Aufsichtsrat, den Gesellschaftsausschuss und Beirat und da muss man wirklich ganz genau darauf achten, wer dort dann reinkommt. Ob es dann wirklich nur Leute aus den Vereinen sind, oder ob das vielleicht Strommänner werden von CVC. Da gibt es ja schon so ein paar Lobbyisten im Hintergrund, das wird immer wieder so dargestellt, dass dieser Ex-Skybox, Carsten Schmidt zum Beispiel, für CVC lobbyiert hat. Ob der zum Beispiel für CVC dort in irgendeiner dieser Gremien sitzen wird und darüber dann die Interessen von CVC vertritt, dann ist er zwar nicht formal angestellt bei CVC, aber ist zumindest Interessenvertreter vor Ort und kann dort Sachen durchsetzen. Ich glaube, da muss man mal abwarten, was dort passiert, aber ich halte es für ziemlich ausgeschlossen, dass man sich dort nicht ins Operative einmischen wird. Ich glaube, diese Themen Spieltagsplanung usw. das ist nicht das erste Thema, wo die ansetzt werden. Das sind eher so Themen, die nachgelagert eventuell mal in die Diskussion kommen, wenn das Investment nicht so läuft, sich nicht so entwickelt, wie sie es prognostiziert haben. Und wenn das z.B. aber gut läuft und die Ziele erreicht werden, dann kann es auch sein, dass es innerhalb dieser roten Linien bleibt. Deswegen muss man viel abwarten. Das ist Zukunftsmusik. Ich glaube da auch nicht dran, aber man muss es einfach abwarten, glaube ich.
Vielleicht noch ein Satz dazu. Die Bundesliga ist ja jetzt schon dabei, international zu vermarkten mit dieser Bundesliga- International-Tochterfirma. So, jetzt nehmen wir mal an, die kriegen ein Angebot aus gegriffenes Japan. Und da sagt ein Sportcaster oder wer auch immer, ich sage jetzt mal was ganz Irres, wenn wir Montagmittag eurer Zeit, wenn ihr da ein Bundesligaspiel machen würdet, jede Woche, dann sagen wir mal 13 Uhr, ich weiß nicht, wie das mit Japan, die sind ja vor uns, also dann haben die da abends, oder? Richtig? Ja, dann haben die da. Dann können wir das hier live zeigen. Wir kaufen jetzt sozusagen eins pro Spieltag und dafür zahlen wir, ich sage jetzt mal, 100 Millionen oder so, weil es ist für uns das Wert. So, wenn jetzt die Bundesliga International die Geschäftsführung zur DFL geht und das den Klubs vorstellt und sagt, pass auf, wir können hier 100 Millionen Cash dafür kriegen, so. Szenario eins. Szenario zwei ist dasselbe und das macht jetzt CVC, wenn die eingestiegen sind, weil die eben da Kontakte haben und das in Möglichkeit sehen. Wie unterscheidet sich dann die Entscheidungssituation für die Klubs? Also diese Themen werden alle so oder so aufs Tapet kommen und die roten Linien sind immer mal der Gestalt wichtig für die Glaubwürdigkeit der DFL. Andererseits hängt die ja auch stark davon ab, wie viel Geld da reinkommt und dieses Spiegelensparat wirst du immer haben, ob nun mit CVC oder ohne CVC und weiterentwickeln, das hat die DFL immer wieder gesagt, müssen sie das Geschäftsmodell und weiterentwickeln heißt natürlich, im Endeffekt du musst über alles nachdenken. Natürlich gibt es immer wieder Grenzen und du wirst immer gucken, wo sind die Grenzen der Clubs, der Fans. Und die sind in Deutschland teilweise enger gestrickt als in anderen Ligen, das ist auch klar. Aufgrund der Tradition, aufgrund der Fan-Kultur, die ist sicherlich speziell bei uns und das ist auch für die Liga ein großer Wert. Aber im Endeffekt müssen die Clubs immer alle rechnen. Was kommt da rein? Und wenn du so ein Angebot kriegst, dann kann es sein, dass es sich das unterscheidet in der Betrachtung, wer es dir besorgt hat. Aber kommen werden die so oder so. Und du musst dich ja auch eintreiben. Die internationale Gesellschaft, die haben ja auch die Liga-Mente schon öffentlich gesagt, bisher nur sehr überschaubar erfolgreich. Wenn du guckst, was die so im Jahr reinholen zu dem, was andere Ligen da schaffen. Jetzt haben die teilweise auch einen Sprachvorteil, keine Frage. Aber trotzdem ist die Bundesliga, glaube ich auch, immer noch v.a. attraktiv. Zumindest attraktiver als die 200 Millionen, die da jedes Jahr zusammen glauben, was jetzt echt nicht viel ist, im internationalen Vergleich. Also ich glaube, die Dinger werden sowieso kommen. Die roten Linien sind politisch wichtig. Am Ende müssen sich alle fragen, wie viel Geld wollen wir, wie viel Geld brauchen wir und wie wettbewerbsfähig wollen wir sein. Natürlich wird der Partner, ob es um CVC sein wird oder nicht, diese Fragen stellen. Die werden die nerven. Und die Leute in der Liga, die das eigentlich auch gerne diskutieren, würden sich aber nicht trauen, direkt zu sagen, die haben dann jemanden, der sagt, was soll das sein, aber die haben gesagt, die holen dann so und so etwas rein. Das ändert einfach die Diskussion ein bisschen. Das ist so, wie ein Unternehmensberater holt, obwohl er eigentlich weiß, dass es bestimmte harte Schnitte machen muss. Dann holt er halt Roland Berger oder wie die alle heißen und sagen, Roland Berger hat aber gesagt, wir müssen euch jetzt rausschmeißen. Ich sag jetzt mal ganz böse, geht ja nicht immer nur darum. Aber nur als Beispiel, dass du kriegst, die Diskussionslage ändert sich. Und ich weiß nicht, was mit den roten Linien passiert. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Kann ich nicht sagen. Vielleicht werden die alle gehalten, vielleicht doch nicht. Aber wenn ich einen Partner hole, will ich mich ja entwickeln. Und die Liga sagt selber immer, ob Partner oder nicht, wir müssen und wollen uns entwickeln. Und die Grenzen dafür wirst du, glaube ich, immer wieder neu ziehen müssen angesichts des Angebotes, angesichts der Marktveränderungen, angesichts dessen, was du willst. Wenn irgendwann die Bundesliga sagt, es gibt ja Leute, die eigentlich sagen, dass uns reicht das völlig aus. Wir sind in Deutschland cool und dem Rest ist uns egal. Wir wollen hier toll Fußball inszenieren. Das kann man ja haben. Ich habe ja gar nicht dagegen. Dann brauchst du das alles nicht. Wenn du aber dich ärgerst, dass du nur noch irgendwie 17-jährige Spieler kriegst, wenn du überhaupt glückliche Kriege und alle anderen gehen nach woanders hin, wo es Mehrgeld zu verdienen gibt und du willst das verhindern, dann musst du dir die Frage stellen, was muss ich dafür tun? Also ist es so.
Ich glaube, ein Punkt könnte halt auch sein, eine rote Linie, die relativ schnell übertreten werden könnte, wäre jetzt bei der nächsten rechten Periode die Frage, ob es an ein oder mehrere Anbieter geht. Also das ist dann die Frage, ob Geld Konzept zum Beispiel überwiegt. Das wurde jetzt ja vom Bundeskartellamt entschieden, dass dieses No Single Buyer Rule abgeschafft wird. Also ist es mittlerweile wieder möglich, dann ist ab der kommenden rechten Periode, dass ein Anbieter – sagen wir mal Sky oder The Zone – alle Pakete quasi erwirbt und von Freitags bis Sonntags da durchsenden darf. Und die Frage ist, sind die Einzelteile in Summe mehr wert als ein Gesamtpaket, was man an einen möglichen Partner verkaufen kann? Und es ist ja ein Problem, dass der Fußball sehr limitiert ist und verschlossen ist durch diese verschiedenen Partner, dass man mittlerweile fast 100 Euro zahlt für alle zwei, drei Partner, wenn man auch noch Telekom damit hinzuzieht. Und jetzt das neueste Paket, aber so wäre, dass man sagt, man hätte jetzt nur Sky und zahlt dafür dann 70 Euro. Dann ist es vielleicht für die Fans einfacher, das hinzubekommen über einen Partner. Aber in Summe würde Sky einfach weniger zahlen als die Summe von Sky, The Zone und Telekom. Und dann wird aber ein Investor definitiv sagen, dann nehmen wir lieber die drei Partner anstatt des einen Partners, weil es gibt uns mehr Cashflow. Und langfristig gesehen wäre es vielleicht sinnvoller, das an einen Partner zu geben, weil mehr Fans sich für Fußball interessieren, weil man das langfristig aufbauen kann. Aber man ist ja auch dann als PE seinen Investoren verpflichtet zu sagen, wir möchten möglichst viel Cashflow drin haben. Und ich glaube, das ist ein Punkt, wo man direkt mal gucken kann, hat der PE. Einfluss oder nicht.
Ja, sehr guter Punkt. Und damit sind wir mitten im ganzen Bereich. Was hat den CVC bisher auch im Sport gemacht? Weil wir haben schon mal kurz angedeutet, sie haben die meiste Erfahrung. Und interessanterweise ganz ähnliche Diskussionen, wie sie jetzt hier gab, gab es beim Rugby-Weltverband, wo CVC eben auch eingestiegen ist. Und da hören wir mal kurz Ian Ritchie, der war früher bei Wimbledon der Chef, hat dafür gesorgt, dass Wimbledon Dach bekommen hat und so weiter und so fort, musste da schon Tradition versus Innovation sehr gut austarieren. Also, dem kann man zuhören. Nicht alles, was er sagt, ist, glaube ich, sinnvoll, aber der hat zumindest Vorerfahrung. Und er erzählt mal, wie es jetzt dann im Rugby-Verband zu dieser Entscheidung kam, man sieht krasse Parallelen zu CVC und dann kommen wir mal drüber diskutieren, was haben sie denn bisher so gemacht bei ihren Sportinvestments?
Also denke ich, wie bei allen Dingen, ja, es war ein gutes Kompromiss.
Und ich denke, es ist interessant, wenn du dann in die unabhängige Negotiationphase gehst, die unabhängig involviert hat, Anwesenden, Täter, sogar in einem Fall, mein Lieblingsfavorit war, algebraische Äquationen in einem der Dokumente.
Also, auch hier, die Vereine mussten sich erstmal alle einig werden. Sie wollten keine Kontrolle abgeben und CVC hat sich aber damit beschränkt, quasi erstmal am kommerziellen Mehrerlös beteiligt zu werden. Alles parallel zur Bundesliga. Man könnte jetzt ganz genau gucken, was wird im Rugby gemacht. Da geht es nämlich auch an die Pfrunde ran. Also, Six Nations, das große Rugby-Event. Da sollte es einen Auf- und einen Abstieg geben. Da haben sich dann noch die Verbände dagegen gewehrt. Aber da passiert schon vieles. Und das ist ja aber eins von mehreren Beispielen. Also, CVC ist auch im Beachvolleyball aktuell drin. Da kann man lesen, dass sich Spieler und Spielerinnen sehr darüber beschweren, dass jetzt weniger Teams nur noch antreten, dass die Preisgelder so gesenkt wurden, dass sich die Anreise kaum noch lohnt. Und bei anderen Turnierserien, die jetzt eben nicht vom Weltverband vermarktet werden, freuen sie sich darüber, dass es Obst und Getränke gibt. Sie waren natürlich lange in der Formel 1 mit drin. Und da hat CVC für elf Jahre sein Investment gehalten. Wie man da reingekommen ist und wie man rausgegangen ist, googelt mal Bernie Eggersdorn und CVC. Auch ganz interessant, die Schleife kann jetzt aber nicht drehen an dieser Stelle. Und da gab es aber z.B. dann sehr, sehr deutliche Kritik. Der Force India Teamchef Robert Fernley hat gesagt, all their actions have been taken to extract as much money from the sport as possible and put as little in as possible. Hat er damals dem Guardian gesagt. Er hat sogar davon gesprochen, die Formel 1 sei, ich zitiere ihn jetzt, vergewaltigt worden von CVC. Das ist ja kein so guter Track-Rocker, Jannik. Also woher kommt dann immer dieses Argument zu sagen, Mensch, die haben so viel Vorerfahrung, ist doch alles toll. Wenn ich versuche zu gucken, was haben sie in anderen Sportarten gemacht, dann ist es immer eine Kostenstrafung und es geht immer vor allem darum, mit allen Wegen dieses Investment auszuquetschen, ist ja klar. Dafür ist man ja eine Private Equity Firma.
Ich will da gar nicht großreden, gegenreden eigentlich. Ich will mich auch nicht als Verteidiger von Private Equity dort in diesem Punkt sehen, auf gar keinen Fall. Was dann aber auf der Gegenseite steht, ist bei der Formel 1, dass der Umsatz von 1 auf 1, 8 Milliarden pro Jahr gesteigert wurde in dieser Zeit in diesen elf Jahren und dass die Ausschüttung an die Teams von 250 Millionen auf 1 Milliarde gesteigert wurde.
Aber andererseits wurden auch traditionelle Rennstrecken, die mussten so viel bezahlen, dass sie kurz vor Konkurs standen und dann also nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern auch Monster und so weiter. Wir haben jetzt Grand Prix 3 in den USA, jetzt schon. Man hat sich völlig daran gewöhnt, dass es Grand Prixs in Wüstenstaaten gibt. Also ja, Wertsteigerung, aber halt da wurden rote Linien definitiv überfahren in diesem Fall.
Absolut. Deutschland hat ja auch drunter gelitten. Also das muss man ja sehen und seitdem Liberty Media bei der Formel 1 drin ist, also die haben das abgekauft damals von CVC, läuft es ja noch deutlich besser. Also man kann ja auch sagen, hey, also seit Liberty Media drin ist, wieso lief es vorher nicht so viel besser noch unter CVC. Also wer weiß, wie es dann ausgesehen hätte, wenn schon, weiß nicht, 2015, es wird ja jetzt immer wieder auf Drive to Survive so als Beispiel abgehoben. Es ist ja unter Liberty Media entstanden und wer weiß, wie es damals dann schon abgegangen wäre. Also man kann es nicht so richtig nachweisen. Also einerseits sind die Erträge hochgegangen, der Umsatz ist hochgegangen. Ja, das spricht auf dieser Seite dann irgendwie für CVC. Andererseits kann man auch gegenhalten, dass Liberty Media seit dem Einstieg da noch mehr erreicht hat. Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu noch sagen soll. Also die CVC ist sicherlich kein angenehmer und einfacher Partner, aber es stehen am Ende oft hier eben auch Erträge. Also aus wirtschaftlicher Perspektive gesprochen ist es meistens sinnvoll. Aber was am Ende dabei liegen bleibt, das zeigt die Formel 1, das zeigt Rugby, das zeigt – in Frankreich, in Spanien gibt es ja auch Probleme mit CVC. Zumindest wird sich immer darüber beschwert, wie dort zum Beispiel in Spanien das CVC zu viel Daten verlangen würde. Das sind so erste Kritikpunkte, die dort kommen. Andererseits wurde auch dort der Umsatz gesteigert. Also wie gesagt, es gibt mal Vor-
Sie kriegen Ergebnisse hin, aber halt mit Kosten, die sehr rigoros sind. Kann man glaube ich schon so sagen, oder?
Das kann man definitiv so sagen. Es ist wie gesagt, es ist ja auch Knall alter Wirtschaft, die dort auf Sport trifft, was ein emotionales Thema ist. Und ich glaube, da kommt es automatisch dann irgendwie zu Zielkonflikten.
Die berühmten Zielkonflikte. Christoph, was sind da deine Gedanken zu? Weil das ist dieses unauflösbare Spannungsfeld, das uns gesagt wird, es wird sich nichts verändern. Und dass sich aber eigentlich alles verändern muss, damit man eine Wertsteigung hinbekommt. Und dass wir auch an dem, was CVC sonst so gemacht hat, eigentlich ganz gut ablesen können. Ja, da verhalten die sich erwartbar. Es wird dann alles verändert, was geht.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir sind fordernde Partner. Ja, das ist klar. Aber ehrlich gesagt, die, die dafür sind in der Liga, die wollen ja auch so einen Partner. Die wollen ja so jemanden haben, der ihnen hilft, ein paar Dinge zu verändern. Und vielleicht die Dinge, die man sonst nicht aufbrechen kann, aufzubrechen. Das Thema Governance, das ich eben schon angesprochen hatte mit der DFL, wenn es zu dem Deal kommt, wird das extrem lebhaft werden von Diskussionen. Das ist klar. Und wir haben, glaube ich, bei uns in der Bundesliga einen besonders großen Spagat dazu leisten, weil eben, wie ich eben schon mal gesagt habe, diese Clubkultur, die EVs, die Fankultur sehr viel tiefer verankert ist als in vielen anderen. In Englern gibt es ja auch Clubs, die so sind, aber das ist schon ein sehr wichtiger Faktor. Das wissen die natürlich auch und die wissen auch, dass das einen Teil der Werthaltigkeit ausmacht. Und die Frage ist ein bisschen auch, wie gehen die dann damit um? Die sind schon flexibel genug, denke ich, um Dinge genau zu studieren, zu wissen oder zu ahnen, was kann man da machen, was kann man von so was nicht. Die werden auch sehen, mal gucken, wie es läuft. Aber ich glaube, dass die schon wissen, dass sie eine gewisse Vorsicht walten lassen müssen. Das heißt, die verhalten sich schon bei jedem Investment noch anders. Die haben zwar ihre Methoden, ganz klar ihre bestimmten Raster, die die über Dinge drüberlegen, Vergleiche, die sie ziehen. Die werden sagen, wenn das zusammen in der Mediaco läuft, wir geben jetzt mal ein paar Vergleichswerte, was kriegen denn andere liegen, was kriegen die dann, wie sieht es bei euch aus? So müssen wir was machen. So werden die die, ich sag mal, attackieren, im Sinne von, so werden die die antreiben wollen. Gleichzeitig hast du auf der DFL die Leute, die sitzen und sagen, wow, so viel ist drin, ist ja irre, ist ja toll. Wenn man das jetzt mal ausrechnet für unsere Clubs, was dann da hängen bleiben würde, sag mal, auch nicht vergessen. Die Clubs wollen das ja auch ein Stück weit. Teilweise wollen die das. Und dann kommst du auf die Frage an, wie kriege ich das zusammen? Und das wird ein andauernder Kampf werden. Das ist klar. Und ich denke, das wissen die in der DFL auch. Und die CVCs wissen das auch, dass sich das dann ständig dann sich reibt. Und welche Grenzen dann überschritten werden, welche nicht überschritten werden, wer wen wie respektiert, welche Leute am Ende den meisten Einfluss haben. Ich finde, das ist extrem schwer vorherzusagen. Und hängt vom Gesamtumfeld ab, hängt davon ab, wie die nächste Ausschreibung läuft. Das wird extrem spannend. Ich befürchte halt, dass es gar nicht so viel passieren wird, weil man sich lahmlegt gegenseitig. Weil ich eben, wie gesagt, schon nicht glaube oder glaube, ich glaube, die DFL wird sich sehr schwer tun, ihre Interessen zu vertreten, wenn die aber keine Gemeinschaft mit ihren Positionen zu bestimmten Kernfragen gegen oder im Schreiber den Investoren aufbauen können, sind die ja nicht handlungsfähig. Und dann wird der Investor auch merken, okay, da kann ich jetzt gar nichts machen, weil es steht alles. Das heißt aber auch, keiner profitiert. Die Gefahr ist auch da. Da hast du einen Deal und der wird im Endeffekt überhaupt nicht richtig, kann gar nicht umgesetzt werden. Oder du kannst nicht die Möglichkeiten erforschen, die du vielleicht hast, weil du einfach gar nicht handlungsfähig bist. Ich glaube, die Gefahr ist relativ groß, wenn es dann dazu kommt.
Ich weiß ja auch so, dass schon sehr viele Dinge vordefiniert sind. Also ich will das jetzt nicht kritisieren, aber es ist ja Fakt, dass die DFL sicher auch aus Gründen, um den Fans entgegenzukommen, nicht nur die roten Linien schriftlich fixiert hat, sondern auch zum Beispiel schon die Geldverteilung ganz genau in Töpfe und so weiter aufgeteilt hat. Und man kann sich ja sehr gut vorstellen, dass eins der ersten Dinge wäre, dass die CVC reinkommt und sagt, ihr wollt 200 Millionen in Antipiraterie stecken, spart's euch, nicht mal die NFL kriegt das hin und die investieren viel, viel mehr. Wir machen das Geld anders und dann ist das zwar vielleicht möglich, aber es ist ja eigentlich schon relativ viel gerade vordefiniert. Es ist fast so, als würden die Vereine sagen, wir wissen ja eigentlich schon, wie wir es am besten machen. Wir haben es ja nur nicht gemacht, weil wir hatten keine Lust in der letzten Zeit. Und jetzt brauchen wir halt die Kohle und deswegen machen wir es jetzt.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, würde ich jetzt, und dass ich es jetzt belegen kann oder auch möchte, es für extrem naiv halten, wenn die DFL so eine Aufteilung da veröffentlicht und wie sie das gerne machen würden, wenn das nicht zumindest in den Grundsätzen mit den Partnern schon mal vorbesprochen worden wäre. Weil das weißt du ja, dass du dann sofort vor die Wand läufst. Und das glaube ich eigentlich nicht. Also ich glaube schon, dass das Teil der Ausschreibungsunterlagen ist und war und dass die Partner wissen, dass der Partner, der mögliche noch übrig ist, weiß, dass das der Plan ist und auch schon in irgendeiner Form gesagt haben wird, kommt ungefähr hin. Und dass die das nicht einfach so mit dem Arsch umschmeißen in der ersten Woche, wenn die Mediacode eingetragen wird. Weil da wissen die ganz genau, dass sie sich damit sofort unmöglich machen. Die Belius ist ja nicht ungeschickt. Aber der weiß natürlich auch, wie er sie erreicht.
Da muss man vielleicht noch kurz einen Hintergrund zu sagen. Ihr wisst das natürlich. Aber er war bei Goldman Sachs vorher und war da zuständig für Daimler Chrysler, den Merger. Er hat dann später die feindliche Übernahme Mannesmann-Voldervorn in Deutschland gemacht. Er war Beraterin von der Regierung Merkel. Also lest euch da mal durch, recherchiert ein bisschen zu ihm. Das ist jemand, der hat jetzt schon ein paar Dinge erlebt. Und wenn ihr eben sagt, harter Verhandlungspartner weiß, was er tut. Ja, also der hat schon ganz, ganz, ganz große Dinge durchgezogen.
Also das wird spannend. Aber wie gesagt, solche Dinge werden in der Regel schon vorher mal abgeklopft. Informell. Wenn das die DFL nicht gemacht hätte, dann könnten die gleich einpacken. Also das glaube ich.
Sie haben es gemacht. Du weißt, das darfst du bloß nicht so sagen. Alles gut. Das ergibt ja auch sehr viel Sinn so. Aber was, wenn wir dann versuchen, zu einem Fazit dieses Gesprächs zu kommen? Ich habe das Gefühl, Jannik, es muss sich was an der Bundesliga verändern. Denn man verdient zu wenig Geld im Vergleich zu anderen Märkten, vor allem eben bei der Auslandsvermarktung. Und die Lösung, die man für sich gefunden hat, ist die einfachste. Nämlich wir gehen nicht an Geldverteilung ran. Wir gehen nicht daran, dass der Wettbewerb ein Wettbewerb ist. Weil dann müssten wir die Großen ärgern, die gerade sehr viel Geld damit verdienen. Sondern man geht den anderen Weg, der auch nicht illegitim ist. Wir verbessern die Art und Weise des Produkts, wie wir es verkaufen. Also wir bauen eben, die Infrastruktur wird verändert. Wir bereiten uns letztlich dafür vor, dass wir zu einem B2C-Unternehmen werden könnten. Also sprich, irgendwann könnten auch Leute bei der DFL ein Abo abschließen und direkt dort die Spiele sehen. Also lässt sich B2B zu B2C-Transformation so ein bisschen. Das scheint der Weg zu sein. Wie erfolgsversprechend, glaubst du, ist der? Wenn CVC jetzt einsteigt, dann könnten ja auch die Fans alles kaputt machen. Wenn die sich absprechen und jetzt für Spielabbrüche zum Beispiel sorgen, das ist, glaube ich, eine nicht so irrelle Gefahr.
Ja, also wie erfolgsversprechender ist, das gibt natürlich sehr viel Spekulation dabei. Also ich bin da irgendwie einfach von berufsfähig auch ein bisschen pessimistisch, glaube ich. Ob das wirklich so diese Wachstumssteigerungen erreicht werden können, das bezweifle ich jetzt einfach mal. Ich würde das halt eher aus einer… Also man hätte das Ganze auch zum Beispiel mit Fremdkapital finanzieren können, dann wäre diese ganze Investoren-Diskussion auch gar nicht aufgekommen. Aber das könnte man diesen Topf ja auch mal aufmachen und sagen, was man davon wegstreichen könnte, wenn man das ganze Fremdkapital finanziert hätte. Dann wären keine 300 Millionen für… die man jetzt vorstrecken muss. Dann wären da keine Ahnung… Weiß nicht, ob man eine Plattform für 164 Millionen bauen muss. Internationalisierung 183 Millionen. Was will Heidenheim in den USA? Das verstehe ich nicht. Kann man auch zusammenstreichen. Was 126 Millionen nationale Töpfe, Piraterie passt, ist natürlich ein Ärgernis. Aber du kriegst es mit rund 46 Millionen wahrscheinlich gar nicht hin. Wie auch immer man es dreht, kann man diesen ganzen Topf auf jeden Fall sehr stark auch eindampfen und man könnte das Ganze dann theoretisch auf Rebkapital finanziert machen. Dafür müssten aber natürlich die Vereine gegenseitig einstehen füreinander. Und das wird nicht passieren, weil Bayern nicht die Schulden von Schalke übernehmen möchte sozusagen. Bayern möchte die für Schalke einstehen. Was ich auch verstehe, aber das würde auf jeden Fall sehr viel Wind aus dieser Nummer nehmen. Und ich glaube halt, dass die Bundesliga – der Unix-Helling-Point der Bundesliga ist ja letztlich nicht, dass man mit der Premier League konkurrieren will, sondern nicht damit konkurrieren kann, oder mit der La Liga, weil die einfach auch ganz andere demografische Vorteile haben, Sprachekultur und so weiter. Und ich glaube, dass man diese Ligen gar nicht aufholen kann, zumindest die Premier League nicht. Die La Liga mag vielleicht in Reichweite sein, was den kommerziellen Umsatz angeht, aber die Premier League ist völlig enteilt. Ich glaube, die meisten Fans geben sich auch völlig damit zufrieden, dass man sagt, wir wollen hin und wieder mal die Premier League ärgern und wollen da mal ganz gerne vielleicht auch mal ein Europa League Finale spielen. Aber so wie es jetzt ist, ist es doch eigentlich ganz schön. Und ich glaube, das könnte man auch einfach durch Kostenregulierung auf eigener Seite mal hinbekommen und damit mal anfangen. Und diese Internationalisierung zum Beispiel, diese 103, 8 Millionen, die ich angesprochen habe, könnte man auch aus eigener Kasse bezahlen. Das könnte FC Bayern, die es ja jetzt bislang auch schon so gemacht haben, einfach so weitertreiben. Also ein bisschen Heidenheim oder Augsburg – oder ich tue mir leid, dass ich diese Vereine jetzt nenne und die dann in den gleichen Topf schmeiße. Da kann ich jetzt noch ein paar weitere nennen, bis die für den amerikanischen Markt interessant werden. Da muss noch einiges passieren. Ich glaube, das wird keiner von uns diese Dreierrunde noch erleben. Ich verstehe diesen Topf einfach nicht, und da fängt es schon für mich an. Deswegen glaube ich, dass dieser ganze Investoren-Deal ziemlich stark zugunsten der Großen wie Bayern und Dortmund geht und die Ungleichheit dieser Liga noch vergrößern wird. Das ist für die Bundesliga sicherlich nicht gut.
Ich denke, dass aus meiner Wahrnehmung schon der Bundesliga wirklich guttun würde, mehr Wirtschafts-Know-How zu bekommen. Dergestalt, dass es aus anderen Branchen einfließt. Weil der Fußball aus meiner Wahrnehmung schon sehr wagenburgartig da steht und sich im Prinzip ja um die anderen gar nicht kümmern muss, weil da geht es rauf und rauf. Und ich glaube, dass der Branche insgesamt bei uns guttun würde. Und deswegen glaube ich, dieses Projekt strategischer Investor ist eine Möglichkeit, um mehr alternative Sichtweisen reinzukriegen und den Fußball voranzubringen. Mir ist klar, dass da viele Grenzen sind, dass das sehr strittig ist, dass das auch ein schwieriger Partner ist. Vielleicht brauchen die in der DFL gerade einen schwierigen Partner. Das kann sein. Der einer, der sehr fordernd auftritt, um einfach ein Stück voranzukommen. Deswegen finde ich das eigentlich richtig. Das gilt auf der Klubebene im hohen Maße, wo du immer mehr Leute hast, die aus der sonstigen Wirtschaft da reingehen. Weil es gibt eigentlich zu viele Fußballer immer noch, die da die Clubs managen und zu wenig Leute, die einfach gute Manager sind. Ich habe mir jetzt lagen lassen vor einiger Zeit von jemandem, der lange im Fußball, der Fußball gut kennt, der sagt, ich kriege ja nicht Anrufe von Leuten aus großen deutschen Konzernen, die fragen, wie kann ich Manager werden im Fußball? Das sind einfach Fans, die wollen da rein und ich finde das cool als Branche und die wissen natürlich auch, da kann man sehr gut verdienen und die sehen dann, ich komme nicht mehr in Vorstand, wie komme ich da rein? Der Fußball ist auch ein Irrenhaus auf eine gewisse Art und Weise und das macht das Managen da echt nicht einfach, aber das tut dem Fußball gut. Ich finde auch, dass man diesen speziellen, dieses Vereinsdenken ein Stück weit braucht, um die Leute an Bord zu halten, um die Fankultur zu behalten. Ich bin selber Jugendtrainer in einem kleinen Verein. Das ist wirklich Verein, Verein, Verein, ohne Geld und nur mit Spaß und Begeisterung und so weiter. Und das ist total klasse, dass es das so gibt. Flächendeckend im Land und das darf man auch nicht riskieren. Ich glaube, dass es Möglichkeiten gibt, da Kompromisse zu finden. Es wird schwierig sein, die auszuarbeiten und alle mitzunehmen. Das ist ganz klar. Und wenn wir das nicht schaffen, dann würde ich sagen, es läuft die Bundesliga-Gefahr, dass wir in zehn Jahren nur noch begrenzt wettbewerbsfähig sind. Und – wir haben gar nicht darüber gesprochen, aber das ist sicherlich schon in anderen Sendungen gemacht – und dass dann Vereinzelclubs sagen, das brauchen wir hier nicht mehr. Die ist ja nicht tot. Und dann gehen die halt raus. Das kann auch passieren. Und dann fliegt die DFL sowieso auseinander. Dann spätestens sowieso. Also wenn es nicht schon vorher passiert.
Also wenn ich so versuchen müsste, so meine Gedanken jetzt auch angestoßen von euch zusammenzufassen. Ich weiß, das wusste ich schon vorher. Wenn man mit Menschen mit wirtschaftlichem Hintergrund spricht, dann blicken die erstmal anders auf dieses. Weil da nämlich auch diese Modelle viel, viel normaler und gelernter sind als eben in der Bundesliga. Ich komme aber an einem Grundgedanken nicht vorbei. Und ich habe das Gefühl, aktuell funktioniert die Bundesliga nicht. Und zwar weder als Wettbewerb noch wirtschaftlich. Ein Teil der Zustimmung für diesen Investorendeal liegt auch daran, weil Vereine jetzt schon zukünftige Einnahmen verkauft haben und dass ihr Mitglieder nicht zugeben wollen. Wir haben ja eine Mehrheit von Vereinen, die das möchte, egal ob das jetzt eine Zweidrittelmehrheit ist oder vielleicht noch eine einfache Mehrheit. Die ist da. Und dafür gibt es Gründe. Und einer der Gründe dafür ist, Vereine sind nicht gut im Wirtschaften. Es ist ein defizitäres Geschäft. Übrigens auch für alle, die bisher Geld oder für viele, die Geld reinstecken, also die Lizenznehmer. Sky gäbe es halt ohne die Bundesliga in Deutschland nicht mehr. Deswegen müssen sie dafür zahlen. Aber Geld verdienen sie damit auch nicht. Und das ist das eine Problem. Wir finanzieren quasi, also wir stecken Geld in ein System, das nicht funktioniert und das dann auch quasi weiter kaschieren kann, dass es nicht funktioniert. Und das zweite Problem, glaube ich, und da will man eben offenbar einfach nicht ran, weil man da so viel im Kopf verändern muss. Die Bundesliga als Wettbewerb ist kein Wettbewerb. Und es spielt eben eine Rolle, ob der FC Bayern Elfmannmeister wird. Und es spielt auch eine Rolle, ob die Alternative zum FC Bayern dann ein Leverkusen ist, das von einem Milliardenkonzern finanziert wird. Und es spielt eine sehr wichtige Rolle, dass du als Köln-Fan und du als HSV-Fan, ihr beide werdet – es tut mir leid – ihr werdet nie wieder deutscher Meister werden, wenn die Bundesliga so bleibt, wie sie jetzt ist. Und das ist ja eigentlich total absurd. Es war noch nie so, dass alle 18 Meister werden konnten, aber es waren zumindest mehr. Und man wusste vor allem eigentlich, wenn sich etwas über längere Zeit verbessert, dann kann man in den Bereich der Teams kommen, die Meister werden können. Und das ist ein ganz, ganz grundlegendes Problem. Und das ist an ganz vielen dann Symptomen zu erkennen, unter anderem eben, dass die Stadien nicht voll sind, dass die Bevorteilung des Fernsehzuschauers vor dem Stadion Zuschauer aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen war, aber dass sie dazu geführt hat, dass das Produkt auch im Fernsehen nicht mehr gut aussieht. Und das sind für mich eigentlich die beiden eigentlichen Themen, die man angehen müsste. Und es kann sogar sein, dass wenn ein Investor reinkommt und der dann der Buhmann ist, man vielleicht manches davon dann umgesetzt und angegangen bekommt. Ich bezweifle es aber irgendwie, weil ich habe das Gefühl, man hat immer noch den Eindruck, wir brauchen nur eine Plattform und dann kaufen schon die ganzen US-Amerikaner und die Chinesen und die Japanerinnen. Die kaufen dann alle ihre Abos. Glaub ich nicht. Glaub ich ja, wenn ich gucke sehr viel Fußball, ich gucke sehr viel Bundesliga, ich kann sagen, das ist nicht immer gut. Hat viele Gründe. Und ich habe das Gefühl, man umschifft einfach nur diese sehr unangenehmen Fragen, verschiebt die auf die Zukunft. Und das ist sehr unbefriedigend, weil das auch für die Fans und die sind halt hier in Deutschland der Kern des Fußballs. Da kann Alex Zorniger erzählen, was man will. Wir haben es während der Pandemie gesehen. Als keiner hingekommen ist in die Stadien, war es ein anderes Spiel und es war fürchterlich. Es gab doch niemanden, der gesagt hat, boah, ich wünsche mir die Geisterspiele zurück. Das war aber geil, wo man gehört hat, was sie sagen. Das ist so mein Gedanke. Und dann haben wir noch 50 plus 1 und 50 plus 1 wird, also in der Art und Weise, wir haben das gerade schon wieder dehnt bis zum Brechen. Das könnte ja sogar dazu führen, dass das Bundeskartellamt nochmal, also wird es jetzt nochmal aufmachen und wahrscheinlich sagt das Bundeskartellamt irgendwann, ey, wenn ihr so viele Ausnahmen immer macht für 50 plus 1, dann muss die Regel jetzt wirklich weg. Es ist eine irre Sackgasse, auf die man da zusteuert. Aber ich danke euch, dass ihr mir diese Sackgasse ein bisschen ausgeleuchtet habt. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, wir haben doch so viele Themen, wir haben gar nicht über Tipico zum Beispiel gesprochen und so weiter und so fort. Wir haben nicht drüber gesprochen, wie die Liga, wie viele da einzelne Menschen verdient haben durch den Einstieg von CVC. Da gibt es jetzt sogar schon Prozesse und so weiter. Vielleicht können wir das mal irgendwann nachholen. Aber vielen, vielen Dank euch, dass ihr mit dabei habt. Herzlichen Dank an Christoph Neßhöver vom Manager-Magazin. Danke dir, lieber Christoph. Und toi, toi, toi für den FC.
Wir können jede Hilfe gebrauchen. Wenn irgendein Stürmer weiß, der auch früher wieder mal ein Tor schießt, würden wir den sofort nehmen, egal wie alt, wie groß, wie klein.
Ich hätte dir Jannik empfohlen, aber der spielt ja defensives Mittelfeld, hat er uns vorhin verraten.
Ja, ich kann es auch nicht machen.
Ich wüsste beim HSV aber auch, ich glaube, da kann euch keiner weiterhelfen, sagen wir mal so.
Und vor allem, ihr dürftet ja, nicht mal Jannik, dürftet ihr ja registrieren. Also da sind ja die Probleme nochmal ganz anderer Art. Aber dementsprechend danke dir, dass du trotz der angespannten fußballerischen Lage trotzdem Lust hattest, über Fußball indirekt zu sprechen. Und dante danke an Jannik Tillar von Kapital. Danke dir lieber Jannik, dass du hier mit dabei warst.
Vielen Dank auch.
Und dann danke ich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Der Rasenfunk ist, anders als die Bundesliga, rein crowdfinanziert. Wir sind paywall, werbungsponsorenfrei, aus sehr, sehr guten Gründen. Und wir werden nur von euch da draußen finanziert. Und in dieser Folge danke ich Tobi W. Steffen, Stefan Hoki-Hoffmann, Clemens Pötzsch, Chris aus MD, Nico Jünke, Jonas und Eiko. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club gegangen, haben uns unterstützt und sich dort auch registriert. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Bleibt gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk gewogen. Bis bald! Von Ihnen unterstützt. Danke. Uns nur der Rasen.